هل عادي أني أتدرب مجانًا؟
المادة ما هو شرط فلوس
ما هي استغلال من الشركات للناس؟
خلّه يستغلني بس يعلمني
الله يرحم والديك، خذ شغفك الحين مو وقته
وتعال شوف سوق العمل أيش يبغى
شغفك ما راح يأكلك عيش
أنا أقدر أصمم لك أفضل مبنى أنت تقدر تبيعه
أنت روح بيعه، وأنت اللي أدر الناس
خلني أصمم لك، أنا ما أبغى أسوي شيء ثاني
ليش تخليني أدير الناس؟ أنا ما عندي مهارات إدارية
ما تبغى تصير مدير، خلك مكانك ولا تطلب لا زيادة ولا ترقية
ليش؟
سقف الراتب حقك لا يمكن يتجاوز المستوى هذا
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
وحدة من أهم مسارات حياة الإنسان هي الوظيفة
تأخذ الوظيفة من معظم حياة الإنسان ومنها نجد رزقنا ونعيش
ومنها نساعد في بناء الأرض وإعمارها وتحسين الحياة
وهذه الحلقة مع مدير للموارد البشرية
حاولت أجد إجابات على الأسئلة اللي تمر بحياة الشخص المهنية
كيف الواحد يختار تخصص؟ من هنا البداية
بعدين، كيف يبني خبرة وهو ما يزال طالب؟
كيف يقدر يكوّن علاقات رغم أنه صعب تكوينها قبل الوظيفة؟
وخصوصًا، أن معظم الوظائف تتم من خلال المعارف
كيف تبني سيرة ذاتية، وهي مهمة جدًّا؟
كيف الواحد يكون جاهز في المقابلة الشخصية؟
اللي هي بتكون آخر نقطة لتحديد هل تتوظف أو لا؟
ولما تتوظف، كيف تتعامل مع الزملاء؟
كيف تتعامل مع المدير والترقيات والعلاوات؟
أسئلة كثيرة، وأجوبة وافية وكافية
من ضيفي نايف الفهيد، خبير في الموارد البشرية لمدة 25 سنة
أما الآن لنبدأ
أنا مرة جبت في الشركة عندنا ركن قهوة
كلّفنا يمكن في الشهر 2000 ريال
نزل لي المدير العام، قال: أنت خبل؟
جايب لك قهوة بـ2000 ريال، ما احنا مستفيدين منه إلا خمسين
قلت له يا أخي: رفاهية الموظف، افهم يرحم والديك
قال: أقول لك أنت وقهوتك اطلع برة
واستغربت قلت له: كم عددكم؟
بس صدق متى تكون رفاهية الموظف؟
سؤال مهم هذا اليوم
أيش جوابه؟
متى تكون أيش؟
رفاهية الموظفة فعلًا مهمة؟
وللا هو دلع لما تكون الشركات؟
لما تشوف انعكاساتها على الإنتاج، لأن أنت تكسب واحنا نكسب
لما تريحه وترفّهه وتعزّه وتعز عياله
وتسوي له تأمين صحي كويس، لا هذه كلها رفاهية
وتداريه صحيًّا و نفسيًّا، وين بيروح؟ في الإنتاج
راح يعطيك أفكار ويبدع ويشتغل
بكرة تتصل عليه وقت أزمة يقول لك: من عيوني الاثنتين
أنا أجيك أداوم بدال الثمانية، عشر ساعات
زي ما أنتم مسوين فيهم الآن
هذه كيف تقاس رفاهيته بصحته وحجم إنتاجيته
خلّه يداوم ساعتين
أيش فيهم ضحكوا؟
لأنهم ما يداومون
أنا أتكلم على القطاع الصناعي الكبير، وقطاع ريادة الأعمال الكبير
في ناس تقول له: لو تتكلّم عن شركته بكلمة ما يرضى
اللي عندهم الولاء العالي زي «أرامكو»
تكلّم مع موظف «أرامكو» واقتله
لأنه هو وعياله لديهم تأمين
وجايبين له بيت ويعطونه خدمة نقل، خلاص
هل هذا دلع، وللا رفاهية أو ليست من حق الموظف؟
لا، هذا من أبسط حقوق الموظف
لأن الرحلة المهنية طويلة
تخيّل أنت تشتغل أربعين سنة من حياتك في هذا المكان
أنا في الوظيفة اللي اشتغلت فيها جلست أربع وعشرين سنة
أربع وعشرين سنة أنا في مكان واحد
بس يشهد الله أن حتى بعدما تركتهم
قبل يومين كان عندي لقاء في «روتانا سيدتي»
جبت طاريهم، ونزلتها في «لينكد إن»
المدير التنفيذي من أمريكا أرسل لي خطاب شكر
أن قلت: أنه احنا عندنا ولاء للشركة، لأن كان لحم كتافنا من خيرها
تزوجنا واحنا موجودين فيها، ومرّينا في أزمات وشالونا فيها
أنا كمدير موارد بشرية مرّت علي منعطفات خطيرة
على موظفين جابوهم بإخلاء طبي، صاروا عليهم حوادث هناك برة
إي، أنت لما تجي تتكلم هذا الكلام قدام الموظف
وتسوي إشاعة، تصدّر للموظفين
يقول لك: أنا وحدة مثل هذه الشركات أقدر أأمّن فيها مستقبلي ومستقبل عيالي
هي كانت أول وظيفة لك؟
الثانية
أيش كانت أول وحدة؟
«شلمبرجير، رقوق بترول»
وبرضو موارد البشرية؟
إي، كانت معاناة
شلون؟
كان أول تكليف أعطاني إياه مدير الموارد البشرية
قال لي: أبيك تطلع إلى الربع الخالي
قلت له: شكلك شايف شهادتي غلط
قال لي: لا أبغاك تشوف
كيف الموظف لما يجي يدق على الموارد البشرية، تعرف وضعه كيف؟
يمينًا بالله، من أصعب أربعة أسابيع في حياتي ما أنساها
لأني كنت أشوف شيء، الموظف يدخل أبيض، ويطلع أسود
لأن الزيت والشحم كله ينزل عليهم، وينقط
ولابسين أفرول إلى هنا، والبوكسر اللي للركبة
في درجة حرارة 55-60، وهو يطبخ من داخل
الله يعزكم، يوصل لمرحلة ما يتعرّق، نشف جسمه
فهذه رسالة بعدما صرت أنا مدير موارد بشرية
كان الموظف أحيانًا يرفع عليك التليفون الساعة 00:00 بالليل
توّه أقول حق الأخت «أصيل» ما تقدر ما ترد عليه
لأن هذا هو الأصول غالية الثمن يسمونها، ما تقدر تعوضه بثمن إذا راح
فدروس قاسية بس تعلّمك كثير
وشلون توظفت أول وظيفة؟
الحين احنا نسجل؟
إي
تمزح! لا
مسموح أنك تقول اللي قلته؟
إي، ما فيها شيء
فكرت ندردش
كلها دردشة الحلقة
ما تمنتجون بعدين، ولا بعدين راح نسأل وللا؟
لا، ما عليك هي زي ما هي، هذه مصيبة
أشوفه ساكت وساكتة
تصدق أعجبني الحديث كذا، أحسن من بودكاستات كثيرة والله
يطالع، ويعدل في السؤال، ويقول: أيش رأيك كذا؟
راحت سوالف السالفة، إي، سمّ
شلون توظفت في أول وظيفة؟
في أول وظيفة، والله قصتها تضحك
أنا قدمت على شركة بترولية، أنا ما كنت بروح
اللي هي «شلمبرجير»؟
إي «شلمبرجير»
ما كنت بروح، ولا في راسي، لأن ما كان توجّهي
ويائس لأن بتوظف فيها
دق علي واحد من عيال خالي
قال لي: أنا مقدم فيها ودقوا علي، تعال أنت
قلت له: يا أخي ما اتصلوا علي
قال لي: تعال معنا
والله رحت، ويمكن في حدود الثلاثين شخص
ليش ما اتصلوا عليك، هل قدمت في مكان قبله؟
ما قدمت أنا، تعرف احنا قبل عشرين سنة
امش بالملف العلّاقي وروح
وسلّم شركة شركة
أنا رحت، حتى من الخجل كنت واقف في الأخير أناظر فيهم
أثاري السالفة الموجودين كلهم سيتم مقابلتهم
وأنا على استحياء كنت واقف في الطابور
في الاختبار التحريري، أنا تجاوزت من ضمن الثلاثين من ضمن العشرة
وولد خالي معي
هو اللي مناديني، وكانوا ما يبون إلا شخص واحد
طبيعة العمل في «شلمبرجير» تحتاج قوة بدنية شوي
أخذنا على ورشة، الورشة الموجودة في هذا
قال: أبغى أوريكم طبيعة عملنا
جابنا عند أنبوب كذا يستخدمونه في تركيب وتفكيك أجهزة الحفر
قال: أبغى أشوف مين يقدر يحركه؟
طبعًا أنا كنت ألعب في النادي والكرة، فطبيعتنا رياضيين
فما حد قدر، كنا نضحك، الشلة الموجودة كانوا يضحكون
ما أقدر أشيله، شوية ثقيل
أنا جيت، بس تعرف حساوي، ويأكل تمر كثير
والله طلع معي، واللي يسوي المقابلة أمريكي ما هو سعودي
فجاءت عينه علي، كأنه خلاص شنّص
هذه الفترة أنا كنت أشتغل عند أحد من أعمامي عنده شركة أصباغ
توني متخرج وكذا، وسعودي ويشتغل...
متخرج موارد بشرية، تخصصك؟
إي، إدارة أعمال
وكنت أشتغل عند عمي في محل أصباغ، يبيع صبغ
كل الموجودين، عمي كان يعطيني 700 ريال
وشهر يعطيني، وثلاثة لا
بس أنا كنت أبي أتسلّى
برضو قال لي الأمريكي، وكانت عندي لغة إنقليزية كويسة وقتها
قال لي: أول مرة أشوف سعودي يشتغل في محل أصباغ
أنتوا ما تشتغلون هذه الشغلات
قلت: عمي، وكنت أبغى أساعده، ومشروعه الجديد
كمان هذه أخذها بعين الاعتبار
أن واحد نازل لمستوى، هو يشوف أن السعوديين ما يتوظفون به
من بين كل الثلاثين، اختارني أنا
وأنا ما قدمت، بس سبحان الله، هذه رسالة
أن احنا إذا كان الله كاتب لك رزق في مكان
حتى لو ما كنت مقدم ومستعد ومتهيئ، بس رزقك موجود ومحفوظ
لأنك لا يمكن تتهيئ لمقابلة وظيفية أنك تروح تشيل أثقال
ما أجى على بالي أقول لك والله، ولا أنا مدعو
الضحك وين؟
أن ولد خالي، واحنا طالعين أنا اللي وقعت العقد
وهو اللي راجع، أحسه يناظر فيني
يقول: ليتني ما أخذتك
كان ممكن أنا اللي أروح
فكانت من التجارب اللي...
وبعدين زي ما قلت لك: وداني الرقوق عشان أسوي محاكاة
أحسها مرة مهمة
إي، وهذه من الاستراتيجيات اللي يستخدمونها المدراء
في أن كيف ترفع الحس الإنساني عند الموظف
أنك تخليه يدخل في معاناة الموظف؟
وهذا يسموه جزء من تهيئة الموظف الجديد
سواءً موارد بشرية أو غيره
أنا تأثرت نفسيًّا كثيرًا باللي شفته، وزي اللي جاءتني صدمة
رعب بأن في أحد اليوم يشتغل هذه الشغلات الموجودين في «الرقوق»؟
هذا الإنسان لما يتصل يقول: أنا أبغى ورقة تعريف بالراتب عشان بروح أقدم
بجي بس اثنا عشر ساعة وأطلع
في بعض الموظفين يقول لك: لما تيجي
الآن المعادلة بالنسبة لي اختلفت، أنت لا تجي، احنا نجيبها لك
أنت وين راح تكون؟
البنك اللي أنت راح تكون فيه، احنا نجيبها لك
لأنه ما عنده إلا اثنا عشر ساعة، لازم يجي يخلص أموره ويرجع
أو موعد عند أهله أو أولاده
فهذا الشيء أنا أسميه أنسنة الموارد البشرية
وهذا الشيء أحيانًا ما تلمسه، وما تلقاه موجود
وهذا في العشر سنوات الأخيرة صار يؤخذ على الموارد البشرية
أنهم قاسين وعنيدين، ودائمًا يطبقون القانون بدون روح القانون
فالتجارب وتهيئة الموظف الجديد لسوق العمل مرة مهمة
حسنًا، كم صار لك خبرة، 25 سنة؟
تقريبًا أنا اشتغلت في الشركة الأخيرة 24 سنة
والشركة اللي قبلها سنة، فكمّلت 25 سنة، وسلمت عليهم
ممتاز، إذا بنأخد تدرج شكل الموارد البشرية أو مفهوم العمل
يبدأ من ما قبل الجامعة، وهو أنك تختار التخصص
وأحس هذه دائمًا مسألة مُؤرقة وصعب فهمها
أتذكر مثلًا في اثنين من إخواني الآن هم في الجامعة
بالصدق قبل يقدمون ما تدري أيش تقترح عليهم؟
وأيش تقول لهم، أو تنصحهم حتى. هل هذا تخصص صح؟
أو هل هذا تخصص خطأ؟
ودائمًا في سالفة اللي أيش سوق العمل يبغاه؟
حتى سوق العمل ما تدري والله أيش يبغى
بغض النظر عن المستقبل اللي احنا نتكلم عليه اليوم
اللي هو الذكاء الصناعي وغيره، خلّه على جنب
الأشياء، الحياة الطبيعية
أحس أنك لا يمكن التنبؤ بما هو التخصص المطلوب في سوق العمل
لو أخذنا السعودية كمثال
تخيل في 2013 تدخل جامعة، تدرس وتقول مثلًا تدرس سياحة
وللا تاريخ وللا أفلام وللا طبخ، مستحيل
يقول لك: ما أحد، لن يقبلها أي عاقل
أنك تدخل هذا التخصص، لأن يقول لك: مستحيل له سوق
والآن كل السوق يطلب هذه التخصصات
فكيف الواحد يختار تخصصه صدق، وكيف يسويها؟
شوف أنت تطرقت إلى حقبة زمنية
اللي في 2013 تقريبًا والفترة اللي ما بعدها
بس اليوم، لو أنا جيت ودخلت في الجامعة
إذا ما كنت مجبر على التخصص بسبب المعدل
فيما أحيانًا أنت تكون انحديت على تخصص، لأن معدلك ما ساعدك
اليوم في قدرات وتحصيلي
وكلما ارتفعت كلما دخلت التخصص اللي أنت تطمح له
السعودية اليوم تتوجه إلى نقلة كبيرة في أكثر من جانب
زي ما نشوف احنا، واضح قطاع الرياضة بدأ يأخذ منحنى مرة ممتاز
الاستثمار والاقتصاد والمعمار
أنت تشوف بدأت المباني والطرق والتشجير والزراعة
فهذا واحد، أول شيء أنت لازم تقيس على البلد أين يتجه؟
قبل، في الخمسة عشر سنة اللي راحت كنا نبحث عن معلمين
بسبب أن الكادر اللي كان موجود في البلد أغلبهم مش سعوديين
فتحول هذا القطاع الآن إلى تقريبًا سعودي 100%
اليوم احنا نفس الشيء الآن
في عندنا وظائف بدأت وزارة الموارد البشرية تسعْودها تدريجيًّا
زي المحاسبين والمهندسين وأطباء الأسنان
لأنهم يبون يحولون إلى الحقبة القادمة أن احنا نسعْود كل الوظائف
أنت أول شيء تحط البوصلة على توجه البلد وين رايح؟
ووين أكثر الأماكن اللي فيها احتياج؟ هذا واحد
اثنين: أنت قد تدخل الجامعة اليوم
وتكتشف أن تخصصك بدأ يقل عليه الطلب
أنت لازم توازن ما بين العرض والطلب
لما أنت تشوف دفعات اللي قبلك تخرجوا
وصعب عليهم أنهم يلقون شواغر
فأنت هنا لازم تأخذ خطوة للخلف
يقول لك المثل: أن تصل متأخرًا خير من ألا تصلَ
فلازم تغير البوصلة وتتوجه إلى توجه آخر، الغلط وين؟
أن في واحد يتخصص إلى الأخير ويتخرج
وهو عارف أنه رايح في مكان الفرص والطلبات قليلة، والعرض برة كثير
تسمح لي قصة صغيرة؟
أنا اتصل علي واحد قبل أسبوع، دكتور أسنان
قال لي: أستاذ نايف أنا تخرجت بعد رحلة سبع سنوات
ما بين بكالوريس وامتياز طبيب أسنان
بس اكتشفت أني أنا ما كنت صراحة حاب السالفة
ماني قادر أتأقلم مع هذا النمط من العمل
قلت له: الحين بعد سبع سنين جاي تقول لي؟
قال: إي والله، أبغى أحوّل إدارة
قلت له: بس حرام، أنت ممارس صحي ورخصة ومهنية
قال لي: أبدًا، أبغاك كيف تساعدني...
هذا المثال يبيّن لك أن الشخص كان ماشي في خط ما هو واضح ومشتت
يمشي وراء الطموح
زيادة على الموضوع، قال لي: أن في البداية أول ما تخرجنا
ما كنا نلقى فرص وظيفية براتب مجزِ
فأريد أن أتحول إلى الجانب الإداري، لأن عندي مهارات
وعندي لغة إنقليزية ومهارات إدارية
فهذا النموذج يبين لك أن الشخص...
أنت لو انتبهت للموضوع بعد أول أو ثاني سنة
أن في عروض كثيرة في تخصصك، والطلبات من السوق قليلة
لازم تغيّر الوجهة عشان تقدر تشوف
وزي ما قلت لك في البداية أرجع للنقطة رقم واحد توجّه البلد
أنا أقول لك: اليوم احنا قطاع الرياضة والسياحة والترفيه والاستثمار والإعمار
هذه التخصصات المطلوبة
أكيد قطاع الطب هو اللي يتصدّر هذا
لأن ما في اليوم طبيب، أكيد في احتياج للأطباء
فهذه القطاعات موجودة
من الجيد كمان، نصيحة أخيرة في هذا الجانب
يا أخي استشير مَن سبقوك في هذا الجانب
لأن الطالب أحيانًا تكون ثقافته في خارج الجامعة قليلة لسه
فشوف لك مستشارين مهنيين، والأكاديميين الموجودين حولك
أخوانك أو أقربائك إذا كانوا موجودين في سوق العمل
ويتابعون الأخبار والبلد، راح يساعدونك كثير في اتخاذ القرار
بس الحمد لله، الأمور طيبة الفترة الجاية
بس التحدي أن عمرك يمكن ثمانية عشرة سنة
وتتخذ قرار مصيري في حياتك اللي هو، وين تروح؟
فكيف يختار الواحد، وهو بهذا السن؟
بعدين تقول: مثلًا بستمر ثلاث سنين، بعدين أكتشف أن تخصصي خطأ
طيب باقيلي سنة واحدة وأخلّص، هل أرجع من الصفر؟
في يسوون تغيير مسار، يمكن ما ترجع من الصفر
بس ترجع سنة للوراء، ولكن أنا تبي نصيحتي؟
ارجع لأنك حتقعد أربعين سنة، وأنت في مكان مظلم
في منطقة رمادية
وأنت تعرف أنك راح تروح في مكان ما راح تقدر تكمل فيه، هذا واحد
اثنين: اليوم صار التوظيف ما يستند بس على الشهادة الجامعية
لازم أنت تكون...
على طاري ثمانية عشرة سنة، أنا قبل ما أقدر أعرف شيء
ومحدود، وما عندي طرق
ثمانية عشرة سنة اليوم، والله يا عبدالرحمن
يعادل ابن خمسة وعشرين سنة اليوم
لأن في مواقع تواصل اجتماعي وبحث وتطور، الجيل تغيّر
فالمفروض أقل القليل أنه يسوي رحلة بحث ليعرف الوظائف المعروضة
ولازم الرحلة في البحث عن التخصص من الثانوي
أول احنا خلاص جيب معدل فوق التسعين، أمورك طيبة
الآن عندك مُفترق طرق ما بين قدرات وتحصيلي
إذا ما قدرت تجيب علامات كويسة ما راح تقدر تصل للي تبغاه
وللا إذا أنك مقرر تروح هندسة، وللا طب، وللا المالية والاقتصاد
ما راح تقدر تلحق إذا ما اشتغلت عليها من قبل
فابن ثمانية عشرة سنة ناضج أكثر منّا قبل خمسة عشر سنة
الحين ممكن يقول لك: أنا بكمل، لأن في دراسات وإحصائيات كثيرة
تقول: أن أغلب الناس يتوظفون في وظائف غير تخصصاتهم
أنت درست إدارة أعمال، الآن تدير موارد بشرية
وأقدر أعدد لك مثلًا برضو عندنا في ثمانية
99% من الموظفين درسوا تخصصات غير اللي يشتغلون فيها
فما مدى أهمية التخصص، وأني أرجع ألف وأستثمر هذا الوقت
بدل ما أستثمره في سوق العمل الحقيقي وكسب خبرة؟
أضيف لك معلومة، في إحصائية سوتها «واشنطن بوست»
بشكل عام أن نسبة اللي يتوظفون في تخصصهم بعد الجامعة
لا يتجاوزون 27%
وهذه نسبة تُعتبر، وين الباقي يروحون؟
وهو هذا الهدف، أن أنت هل تنتظر أنك تلقى تخصصك بعدما تتخرج من الجامعة؟
قطعًا، بناءً على الإحصائيات اللي قلتها
و«واشنطن بوست» اليوم سوّت إحصائية كبيرة
هو الطبيعي أن الواحد لما يتخرج، 27% بس هم اللي من المتوظفين
والباقي تقريبًا حدود 80% راح يتوظفون في غير مساراتهم
الآن يجي التحول، والمرونة
وكيف أن الشخص ممكن أن يؤدي، وينجز في مكان آخر؟
أنا تخصصي إدارة أعمال بس 50% منها تعتبر إدارة، بعدين أعمال
بس لما توظف الإدارة هذه في إدارة الموارد البشرية
راح يُفتح لك السوق، ولما تحصل على شهادات احترافية
زي «شارم» و«سي اي بي دي» وتتطور في الموارد البشرية راح تقدر
إضافةً إلى أن بيئة العمل راح تساعدك كثير أنك تتحسن
أنت ضربت مثال هنا في ثمانية
قطعًا أن الشباب أخذوا تدريب، وبدأوا يتبادلون الخبرات
وهم اللي كانوا العام غير اللي هم السنة صاروا وتغيروا
ومهاراتهم اختلفت، صاروا أكثر
فبالعكس، الشخص أحيانًا تغيير المسار المهني
حسب متطلبات السوق، أنا أعتبره ذكاء
إضافةً على كذا أنك أنت لازم تتطور، لازم تُعِد نسخة جديدة منك
لا يمكن اليوم، الخريج الجامعي يستند على الشهادة الجامعية
في زمننا هذا، انسى الموضوع، إي والله، لازم..
عدا الطب طبعًا، لازم تكون تتمتع بمهارات مختلفة
ولازم تكون محَضّر للمرحلة القادمة
اليوم أنا أقول لك: 90% من الوظائف المطلوبة في السوق
كلها تحتاج لغة إنقليزية
لك أنت تتخيل اليوم، أنا تخصصي اقتصاد بس ممتاز في اللغة الإنقليزية
في الاقتصاد أقدر أشتغل في البنوك، والمحاسبة
لأن في رابط يقدر يربطني، وأفهم لغة الأرقام
بس اللي ودّاني هناك امتيازي في اللغة الإنقليزية
فالواحد لازم أنه يجهز للمرحلة القادمة، هذا أهم
أيش المهارات غير اللغة الإنقليزية المطلوبة غير شهادتك؟
اللغة الإنقليزية تعتبر رقم واحد
مهارات «مايكروسوفت» مثل «إكسل» و«داشبورد» و«البوربوينت»
والعروض التقديمية، هذه من المهارات اللي لو تواجدت في شخص...
احنا لما تجي تدخل في مقارنة ما بين الموظفين
قطعًا لو اثنين تخرجوا بنفس التخصص، ومن نفس الجامعة وبنفس المعدل
راح تبدأ هذه الفوارق هي اللي تضيف لك قيمة...
اللغة الإنقليزية، ومهارات الحاسبات، تحديدًا برنامج «الإكسل»
اللي هو يعتبر شيخ البرامج في «المايكروسوفت»
واللي يساعدك أصلًا أنك تنجز المهام بضغطة زر
لأن احتياج السوق يبدو أنك أنت شرحته وأكّدت عليه
بس يبدو لي أن برضو ما يزال مسألة نسبية
صعب أنك تحدد أيش يحتاج السوق
أتفق معك
فهل يجي الطالب يقول: أنا بدرس اللي أنا أهتم به
فبدرس في شيء شغفي موجود فيه، ومن ثم نقرر بعدين
نشوف أيش الحياة تصير
إما لأن شغفي سيقودني لأكون مميز في هذا المجال الذي سيحتاجه السوق
أو أني أنمي مهاراتي في مكان أحبه
وبعدين عادي إذا توظفت في مكان ثاني، ليكُن
شوف تبغى تمشي مع العاطفة، وللا مع العقل والمنطق؟
العقل والمنطق
اليوم إذا أنا راح أختار عاطفتي وشغفي
وعارف أن الخطة واضحة وراح أنجح فيها، توكل على الله
ولكن إذا المنطق اليوم، يقول لك: أن تخصصك هذا ما راح يأكلك عيش
قطعًا في بعض الناس اللي عندها شغف في التكنولوجيا
وفي نظم المعلومات، يعرف خط سيره
أن من وأنا صغير كذا، والسوق يبغى
بس أنت مثلًا شغفك في الحرف اليدوية أو الرسومات
والسوق اليوم ما يطلبه
فالله يرحم والديك، خذ شغفك الحين مو وقته
وتعال شوف سوق العمل، أيش يبغى؟
لأن أنت وراءك مستقبل وأولاد وحياة كريمة
وتبغى تعيش منها، ويمكن عليك التزامات مالية
إذا شغفي ما راح يعيشني اليوم، ويخليني أقدر أواكب متطلبات الحياة
شغفك ما راح يأكلك عيش
فما هو معناته أنك تنسى الشغف
ممكن في لحظة من اللحظات يكون هذا عمل تجاري ثاني لك
ممكن أن الشغف أحيانًا تجي له مرحلة، ويكون له اهتمام
ولكن أنت لازم تتبع العقل والمنطق
لأن بكرة راح تروح وما راح تقدر ترجع
وهذا شيء ودّى ناس كثير في ستين داهية
والله؟
إي، وفي ناس نجحت، قطعًا أنا أعرف أن في ناس
الشغف لما يكون مرتبط بالعصر الحالي، وبمتطلبات السوق
اللي قاعد يصير في البلد وتطورها، الشغف راح وإيّاه
في ناس اتبعت شغف ما هو مطلوب في السوق وفي البلد
على فكرة في ناس اضطرت تطلع برة البلد
عشان احنا ما عندنا الاهتمام هذا، واضطر أنه يروح برة
ويأخذ أسرته ويتغرب
لأنه يقول: أنا شغفي ما هو موجود في البلد؟
أيش حدك من البداية؟
فأنا دائمًا أقول: الوسطية ممتازة، والمرونة هنا مطلوبة
أنك تتبع المنطق والعقل وحافظ على شغفك
قد يكون في يوم من الأيام تتاح لك الفرصة
احنا كلنا واحنا صغار كنا نحب الكرة
وكنا نحلم نلعب في الهلال والنصر، ونادي الاتفاق بما أني من الشرقية
وكان شغف، ولعبنا في المراحل السّنية
وكان عندنا حلم نلعب في المنتخب
بس مع مرور الوقت بدأ الشغف هذا يقل
لأن ما تقدر تواكب النجوم والعالميين، فحولنا المسار
والحمد لله حولنا، وللا كان الحين احنا رياضيين
وشفنا أمثلة ما هي طيبة في اللي ما قدروا يوصلون الرحلة
على سبيل المثال
بس رحنا مع المنطق وكملنا دراسة
وما زال الشغف موجود هذا احنا نشوف، ونتابع ونحضر رياضيًّا
بس أرجع وأعيد أأكد، الوسطية زينة
حياتك ومستقبلك أهم، وحافظ على شغفك يمكن الله يفتحها لك في مكان ثاني
الحين كم عدد الناس اللي وظفتهم خلال مسيرتك؟
كثير
50 أو 1000 أو 2000؟ تقريبًا
بشكل مباشر وقّعت لهم عقود، لأن أحيانًا ما أكون أنا صاحب القرار
فاللي وقعت عليهم أن يكونوا مجتازين من عندي
تقريبًا خلال الرحلة هذه تجاوزوا الـ 500 أو 400 في هذا النطاق
بس كان في منهم قرارات صعبة كانت
ممتاز، فالحين عندك 500 بشكل مباشر
تقريبًا
وفي أكثر منهم أضعاف بشكل غير مباشر لكنك اطلعت على الإجراء
كنت جزء من...
العملية
إي، جزء من اللي احنا نسميه فريق المقابلة الشخصية، لجنة المقابلة
ممتاز، فالآن كم واحد جاءك بتخصص ورفضته لأجل تخصصه
لا لأجل أي شيء ثاني؟
جاء ويبغى يتوظف ما أعرف تسويق، بس تخصصه قانون
تقول له: يا أخي أنت تخصصك قانون، آسف
والله أحس أنك ممتاز، مدير التسويق في الشركة يقول ممتاز
بس لا والله، تخصصك قانون آسف ما أبغاك، أو أي تخصص ثاني
أو واحد برضو قانون، ويبغى يشتغل في الموارد البشرية
ما أدري أنا ليش شايل على القانون بس.....
في أحد قانون؟
هذا قانون
لا شوف أبو عمر
فودّي أعرف بالاستشهادات وفقًا لتجربتك
احنا في شركة شوي متقدمة في هذا الموضوع
لا يمكن أن أسمح أني أنحط في موقف مثل هذا
أو أجيب شخص وأحطه في موقف مثل هذا
والسبب أن احنا نصفّي السير الذاتية قبل أن أجلس مع الشخص
أنا أعرفك، قرأتك قبل أن أجلس معك في المقابلة الشخصية
وهذه رسالة لكل الموارد البشرية
لا يمكن أستدعي شخص لأن هذا ممكن جاي من برة المنطقة
احنا في الشرقية وللا الرياض، وهذا الأخ جايني من الشمال أو الجنوب ومتكلف
أجي أقول له: أنت هذا التخصص، واطلع برة
هذا خطأ كبير وظلم في حق هذا الشخص
عندنا احنا معيار معين نمشي عليه، أن تُصفّى السير الذاتية
وتستعرض واحنا نختار التخصصات اللي نبيها
وصارت مرت علي مواقف كثيرة
يقول لي: لما رحت، قالوا لي: هذا المثال اللي قلته صحيح
قالوا لي: أنت تخصصك ما هو مرغوب عندنا
طيب ليش استدعيتني للمقابلة الشخصية؟
معناها في حلقة ناقصة موجودة في عملية المقابلات الشخصية
وهذا خطأ كبير
فأنا ما مر علي شخص أمانة، لا يمكن...
ما بدأنا المقابلة الشخصية، أقول له: أنت تخصصك
ولكن في بعض حقين الموارد البشرية، الله يهداهم
أحيانًا لما الشخص ما يجتاز المقابلة الشخصية
يحط هذه شماعة
يحط هذا العذر
طيب هل قد وافقت على شخص في تخصص غير تخصصه اللي درسه؟
إي، الحين راح أقول لك، هذا مثال كويس
أحيانًا يجيك الشخص على أساس أنه مهندس
واحنا طالبين مهندس في قسم المشاريع
ولكن من خلال المقابلة الشخصية أنا كموارد بشرية
وزميلي اللي هو خبير المهندسين
المهندس عادةً يسأل الأسئلة التقنية البحتة في مجال الهندسة
أنا خلال المقابلة الشخصية أكتشف أن الشخص
يا أخي عنده قيادية ومرونة عالية، وحب العمل الجماعي
إضافة إلى كذا، كان إيجابي كثير في المقابلة الشخصية
أنا أقيس الشخصية
أمور تتعلق بالشخصية من خلال الأسئلة اللي أنا أوجهها
زي ما قلت لك، المرونة والعمل الجماعي والطموح والشغف
زميلي المختص في الأمور التقنية
قال: أنا أحس أن هو مش اللي أبحث عليه
لأن عندنا علامات احنا نحط عليها
أنا أعطيته علامات عالية جدًّا، وخليته عندي
إلى أن نضطر أحيانًا أنك ما تلقى شخص بهذه المواصفات
وفعلًا وظفت شخص هندسة في تخصص إداري
وما أبغى أقول لك: اليوم هو في إحدى الشركات مدير موارد بشرية
لأنه عنده مهارات عالية الرجل قيادي، ومهاريًّا كويس
عنده شغف وحب في الإدارة، ولكنه مهندس
وهذا ما يعني أنه ما درس مواد إدارة، بس اطلاعاته كثير في الإدارة
أحيانًا في حاجات تجي في الشخصية نفسها
القيادية والمرونة والجماعية والإيجابية، ما تلقاها في كل واحد
فأحيانًا أنت تنتقي شخص تعرف أنه مناسب للمنظومة اللي تشتغل فيها
فصارت كثير
ففكرتي الحين هل فعلًا التخصص، بعدما خلصت الجامعة
له قيمة حقيقية في مسارك المهني؟
وللا هي قيمة حلوة إذا عندك بس إذا ما عندك مو نهاية الـ...
إذا ما كانت التخصصات دقيقة
في الطب وبعض الأمور الهندسية
اللي ما يمكن ،لا تجيب لي مهندس كهربائي
وتقول: ببدله بجيب واحد متخرج إدارة، هذا جانب معين
ولكن ما فيها كلام ومليون في المئة
وأتفق معك بكل ما تعنيه الكلمة، التجارب والنجاحات كثيرة
مرت علي حالات كثيرة، أن الأشخاص خارج التخصص أبدعوا كثيرًا
هذا واحد منهم مثال كويس
والله التجارب كثيرة والمشكلة اللي ما كنت أصدقه من خلال التجارب اللي شفتها
أن كثير من اللي وصلوا لشخصيات مهمة، ومنصب نائب رئيس
أصلًا تخصصهم كان اللي متخصص مختبرات أو إدارة أو هندسة
أو إلكترونيات أو نظم معلومات
بس التطور المستمر للشخص يوصلك إلى مكان ما تتخيلها
وأحيانًا تطغى العوامل الشخصية على التقنية
أيش تقصد؟
بمعنى أن الرجل يحب يتطور ويتعلم ويتعامل مع الناس
وعنده طريقة وأسلوب في أنه يقود مجموعة كبيرة
جيد في العمل الجماعي، ويقدر يحقق نتائج، ويتخذ قرارات
ويطلع من أزمات، فيه له سجل عالي كثير
يخليه يوصل بعيد كل البعد عن التخصص حقه
واحنا في البلد عندنا أمثلة كبيرة وكثيرة وصلوا إلى وزارات خارج تخصصهم
أمثلة كثيرة «الدكتور توفيق الربيعة»
دكتوراة في الحاسب الآلي، ولكنه...
وكان وزير الصحة قبلها
واللي كان وزير التجارة، والآن وزير الحج
وهذا واحد من الأمثلة اللي اليوم في السعودية صار يُحتذى فيه
واحد من الأمثلة في الوزارة أنه وصل شخص من أعلى المناصب في الدولة
خارج تخصصه، وصارت تُستشهد في أماكن كثيرة في البلد
صحيح، الحين تخرج من الجامعة، ويبدأ يبحث عن فرص وظيفية
عادةً اليوم معظم الوظائف لما يُعلن عنها في أي مكان يُشترط الخبرة
وعادةً حديثي التخرج ما عندهم خبرة
فكيف حديث التخرج يقدر يكتسب خبرة؟
طيب شوف هذا سؤال يُطرح كثير على الخريجين
وصراحةً يؤسفنا أن نلقى شركات كثيرة
تدور على هذا الجانب كثير خصوصًا مع الخريج
ولكن، اليوم في شيء في الجامعة يصير أن أحيانًا شخص يغفل عنه
في المجالس الطلابية والأندية الجامعية في الجامعة
أنا قريب، لأن ابنتي تدرس في الجامعة
وقبل فترة كانت متصلة علي تقول لي: نبغاك تقدم لنا محاضرة
لأن أنا في المجلس الطلابي، وأنا واحدة من المنظمات
وغصبًا عنك لازم تجي تقدم لنا التدريب في الجامعة
فقلت لها: أنتم أيش الأنشطة اللي تسوونها؟
قالت: أنا اللي أتواصل من خارج الجامعة عشان أوفر
دورات تثقيفية وتدريبية لنا احنا طلاب الجامعة
فهذا أعتبره فعالية معينة، هي كانت تدير فعاليات
هذا جزء كبير يعلمونك إياه الجامعة
في المقابل في طلاب من يدخل الجامعة إلى أن يطلع
هو وزميله بالغرفة ما يعرفون أحد
وهذا يؤثر عليك في سلوكك وعلاقاتك ومرونتك، حتى في شخصيتك
فتقدر تكتسب خبرات قبل أن تتخرج من الجامعة
العمل الصيفي والتدريب التعاوني
أنت بعدما تتخرج من الجامعة، هذه أول محطة في أنك تكتسب الخبرة
إذا ما قدرت تستفيد أقصى استفادة من هذا التدريب التعاوني
أنت ضيعت فرصة كبيرة عليك
أنا وظفت ناس كثير من هذا المكان؛ لأنه وفّر علي مقابلة شخصية
ووفّر علي سيرة ذاتية وفرز وعقود ورواتب
اكتشفت أن هذا لا يفلت، هذا لا يروح مكان
وهو كان مُتدرب؟
وهو كان متدرب، ووقّعنا وإياه عقد مبدئي
قلنا له: مكانك موجود، روح وكمل إذا باقي لك كم فصل في الجامعة
آخر فصل هناك
ويجي كثير، وكثير صارت، فخبرة قوية يستفيد منها
بس مهم جدًّا أنك تختار الجهة اللي تقدر تضيف لك قيمة
فالخبرة تأتي خلال الدراسة الجامعية، وأول ما تتخرج من الجامعة
الآن نرجع للي تخرجوا، وحكم عليهم الزمن أن ما عندنا خبرة
هنا عندك طريقين: الأول الأعمال التطوعية
الأعمال التطوعية مرة ممتازة إذا كان في لها عائد مهني وتقني
يضيف لك قيمة في تخصصك ممكن تتوجه إلى الأعمال التطوعية
والجمعيات الخيرية، وفي شيء يسمونه العمل الجزئي، وفي الفعاليات
والأعمال الموسمية، يحتاجون كثير
نشوفهم كثير في الأعمال الموسمية والمهرجانات الكبيرة اللي تصير
هذا كمان لما تكون أنت مشرف على مجموعة
ولما تقود هذا الجزء، وتُدير الشباب الموجودين
عندك أهداف وخطط لازم تحققها بعدما نخلص
فتمر في مشاكل وأزمات
في النهاية أنت لما تجلس قدامي في المقابلة الشخصية
تقدر تبيّن لي أنك احتكيت في بيئة عمل أو مجتمع موظفي معين
تعلمت، أيش معنى فريق ومدير وأهداف؟
اللغة تتغير مع الشخص اللي يكون عنده خلفية ولو بسيطة في بيئة العمل
هل عادي أني أتدرب مجانًا؟
لفترة معينة، ومجانًا تقصد فلوس؟
إي فلوس
طيب أنا لو قلت لك: أنك راح تقعد ثلاثة شهور
بس بعدها أنا متأكد أنك ستجيد اللغة الإنقليزية، هل تعتبره مجانًا؟
لا
لو قلت لك: أنك بعدما تطلع من هنا
راح أجهزك حق أي شركة تسوي لك مقابلة شخصية
لأن راح تكون عندك مهارات في «الإكسل» مرة كويسة
فالمادة ما هو شرط فلوس، بس ممكن تكون مهارة
وهذا هو اللي يهتم فيه الخريج اليوم
بس لا تصير لمدة طويلة مجانًا، لأنها راح تؤثر عليك نفسيًّا، أتفق معك
كم المدة المنطقية؟
أعتقد ثلاثة شهور مرة مناسبة
ما هي استغلال من الشركات للناس؟
خلّه يستغلني بس يعلمني، أنا جاي معليش استغلني هذه الفترة
بس أبغى أطلع من عندك، وأنا اكتسبت مهارة
حتى اليوم أنتوا عندكم، ويمكن هنا تيجي تجرب لواحد ثلاثة شهور
وممكن يثبت أنه شخص قوي وجيد
وإذا ما أثبت أكيد ما راح يطلع زي ما أول يوم دخل عليه
ومو كل شيء المادة
حسنًا، الحين أنت قلت: أن في مهارات مهمة غير الشهادة
وحطيت أنت اللغة الإنقليزية
ومهارة «مايكروسوفت» وتطبيقاته
في المقابلة الوظيفية، كيف ممكن أثبت أن هذه المهارات عندي؟
أفتح «مايكروسوفت»؟
في المقابلة؟
إي، أو في غيرها، بس كيف وأنا أتقدم للوظيفة؟
في مهارات الحاسب الآلي، وللا المهارات بشكل عام؟
الحاسب الآلي أو اللغة الإنقليزية
إذا في المقابلة الشخصية، في السيرة الذاتية مكتوب فيها كل شيء عنك
هي بطاقة تعريفية عنك، وأنا قرأتك وعرفتك
وعرفت هذا الشخص اللي أمامي عنده
إذا كنت كاتب لغة إنقليزية راح أسحبك وأحطك في زاوية
وأبدأ أسألك في اللغة الإنقليزية
قد ما تكون واصل إلى مستوى عالي في اللغة الإنقليزية
احنا اليوم واحنا نعتبر نفسنا ندّعي أن احنا جيدين في اللغة الإنقليزية
بس لما أُرسل إيميل بمستوى عالي أنا أخاف أكتبه
أروح أشوف شخص مُختص في اللغة والخطابات
قطعًا راح يكون محترف أكثر مني
فإذا أنت كاتب لغة إنقليزية راح أسألك بعض الأسئلة
عشان أتحقق بس، وين ممكن أستفيد منك لو وظفتك في هذه الوظيفة؟
بالنسبة للتطبيقات، نعم أحيانًا خصوصًا لما نصير في المحاسبة
في المصروفات والجرد، أطلب منك مثال حي
وأعطيك اللابتوب بالضبط زي ما قلت، هذا اللابتوب أبغاك تسوي لي هذا المثال
نعطيه مثال، أن هذه ميزانيتنا السنة، وهذه مصروفاتنا فيها
أبغاك تطلع لي الأرباح والخسائر المتوقعة
ويدخل يسوي ويحط المعادلات ويثبت، لأن هذا ما تثبتها إلا بالتجربة
مش كل مَنْ كتب مهارة أنه ما عنده، بس لازم تقيس مستواها
كيف ممكن أسوي سيرة ذاتية بشكل مثالي؟
هل في قالب محدد، وللا المفترض أسويها بطريقة معينة
وأكتبها من شركة لشركة؟
راح أبدأ مما انتهيت، حلوة من شركة لشركة
مش من شركة بالضبط
من وظيفة لوظيفة أو من مسمّى لمسمّى
وهذا هو اللي يميز السيرة الذاتية اليوم
راح أجيك على القالب، بس أبغى أوصل رسالة
أن كل مسمّى وظيفي يحتاج لسيرة ذاتية
أنا اليوم دارس إدارة أعمال، والمتقدم عليها موارد بشرية
هل أقدر أميل إلى هذا الجانب؟
راح أبرز الجانب اللي يتعلق بالموارد البشرية، وبقوتي في الإدارة
إذا أنا حاصل على شهادة في الموارد البشرية، ودورة في التأمينات الاجتماعية
وفي قوة عندي
راح أبدأ أشكل وأفصل السيرة الذاتية زي ما يبغى المسمّى الوظيفي
فالجزئية الأولى أن من الخطأ أن يكون عندي سيرة ذاتية واحدة
وهذا 90% من الطلاب يخطئون فيه
يقول لك: أنا متخصص اقتصاد
معناها أروح أكتب كل شيء له علاقة بالاقتصاد
خطأ، أنت دارس 4 سنوات في الجامعة، لا يمكن دراستك كلها اقتصاد
وممكن عندك شهادة كويسة ضافت لك قيمة
وممكن أنت محترف في «الإكسل»
وأنا نسبة احتياجي في تطبيق «الإكسل» في هذه الوظيفة
أكثر من الاقتصاد حقك
أو أن ممكن ما أحتاجه نهائيًّا فقيمته ما تساوي شيء
بالضبط، فأنت شكّل ولوّن سيرتك الذاتية ووجهها إلى المسمّى الوظيفي
كثير يلفت انتباهنا، خصوصًا في أقسام التوظيف
يدورون على كلمات مفتاحية معيّنة
ما يدورون على تخصص معين فقط، التخصص زي ما قلنا قبل شوي
يحتاج في الوظائف اللي تحتاج، دقيق لازم تكون تخصص معين
بس عدا عن ذلك، لا أنا أسعى إلى منظومة متكاملة في هذا الخريج
وهذه والله رسالة، إن شاء الله، تصل للكل
شكّل سيرتك الذاتية بناءً على المسمّى الوظيفي، هذا واحد
اثنين: من الأخطاء الشائعة ما دام احنا نتكلم
لا تخلي أحد يكت سيرتك الذاتية
من الغلط الكبير، أنا أتكلم عن تجارب، والله عبدالرحمن
شفت أحيانًا، أسأل أسئلة يقول لي: ورني وين مكتوب؟
أنا هنا أنجلط ، صارت للكثير وأقول له: خذ، وفهّمني
وقتها تكون أنت أنهيت المقابلة أول شيء
لأن شوف الموارد البشرية حساسين مع المصداقية كثير
حسيت أن اللي بعد رحلة أكاديمية
ما كلف على نفسه يبذل مجهود أنه يسوي له سيرة ذاتية كويسة
هذا أعتبره إنسان مُهمل قليلًا، فما ينفع في المنظمة
أنت تونا في البدايات وأنت كذا، بس وين؟
أنت شغّل مخك كويس، اكتب سيرتك الذاتية بيدك
اكتبها أنت على أي برنامج، وأعطها لواحد يسويها لك
لا تضيف ولا تنقص ولا تحط، وراجعها
مرّت علي برضو حالات
قال لي: أنا اللي كتبتها بس مش أنا اللي صممتها
وهذه؟ قال لي: هذه الإضافة الظاهر نسخ ولصق من سيرة ذاتية ثانية
صارت كثير، فخلي واحد يصمم
على الرغم، والله ما هي محتاجة هذا كله
هو ملف «وورد» ومقدمة عنك وتخصصك الجامعي، خبراتك ومهاراتك
ما تبي أكثر من كذا السيرة الذاتية
التصميم ما يفرق معكم؟
التصميم هو اللي يؤذيننا
والله؟
إي والله، شفت التزيينة هذه
لأن احنا نعتمد في السيرة الذاتية في الأصل على الاستبعاد
في الأصل نستبعد السيرة الذاتية المش مطابقة
فأنت تشوف ألوان غريبة، مع الطباعة لما نطبعها
وخصوصًا البنات يحطون ألوان كثيرة ويحطون الصورة
بالحجاب هذه اللي تعتبر زي الظل
ما له داعي، ما أبغى أشوف هذا كله أنا
أبغى اشوفك أنت، كيف قمت سويت السيرة الذاتية عشان...؟
احنا ليش نسوي السيرة الذاتية، ولمين نسويها؟ للموارد البشرية
في ناس تسوي السيرة الذاتية لها
لا، أنا أعرف أنك فاهم نفسك
بس أبغاك كيف تخلي الموارد البشرية يقرؤونك، فهذه النقطة مفصلية
ملف «وورد» تحوله إلى «بي دي إف»
بدون خطوط وسطور، منظم والتواريخ متسلسلة
أنا أسميها السيرة الذاتية الزمنية التاريخية
أحيانًا يجيك واحد يحط أن عنده خبرة في 2023
بس متخرج في 2015
فليه تبهدل مسؤول التوظيف؟
لأن مسؤول التوظيف قلت لك: في الأصل يستبعد
لأنه عنده 500 ويبغى يطلع منهم عشرة
فكل شيء ما يتماشى معه
على طول شيل
وبعدين احنا بشر، أنا متأكد أن هذا الشخص أحيانًا يتضايق
ويبدأ يلعب على الألوان، يقول لك: راح أستبعد اللي عليها ألوان
وراح أستبعد اللي فيها خط صغير...
طيب اقرأها، يقول لك: تعبت ما راح أقدر أركز كثير
فأنت ريح، سيرة ذاتية على ملف «وورد» ومكتوب فيها كل شيء بوضوح
في صفحة واحدة، هذا إذا أنك خريج
عاد أنت متقدم، وعندك خمس أو عشر سنوات
قد يتطلب أكثر من صفحة
صفحتين أو ثلاث لأن إنجازاتك كثيرة والمنصب اللي أنت مقدم عليه كبير
فمحتاجين أن نشوف إنجازاتك، ونشوف وين اشتغلت، وكيف تحركت
تسلسلك المهني، هل أنت اليوم بدأت قائد بعدين صرت مدير
بعدين صرت مدير مجموعة، بعدين صرت مدير عام؟
هذا التسلسل مطلوب أن احنا نشوفه في السيرة الذاتية
عودةً على سؤالك، أبسط من ورقة السيرة الذاتية ما في
إي والله
الصورة مهمة؟
الصورة غير مهمة، وأتمنى أن ما أحد يحطها
والله؟
إي والله، ليش؟
حسب التدريبات اللي أخذناها أن...
في فصل أخذته برة أيام الشركة
كان يقول لنا: الإنسان، سبحان الله، ما كنا منتبهين لها
أول كنا نقول: حط صورتك عليها
الإنسان أحيانًا يحكم بالنظر
العين، زي الأكل أنت تشوف الأكل يمكن مش طيب
بس شكله كويس في قائمة الطعام، فتطلبه
وهذا الشي يصير لأن مجموعة مشاعر الإنسان
فممكن يختار، ويقول: والله ذكي
والله شكله يجي منه، والله شكله أنيق أنا محتاج...
ما أحتاج هذا كله، كل اللي أحتاجه أني أقيس جدارتك
واستحقاقك لهذه الوظيفة من خلال سيرتك الذاتية
ما أبغاك تؤثر على مسؤول التوظيف من الناحية الخارجية
وهذه كنا دائمًا نحرّص أن لا تستقبلون السيرة الذاتية اللي فيها صور
لأن راح تدخل في جزئية لا تتعلق بالتوظيف
أيش الأخطاء الشائعة غير هذه في السير الذاتية؟
والله في أخطاء كثير
مثل؟
تُرفَض الأخطاء الإملائية بشكل كبير جدًّا
إذا أنت كتبتها باللغة الإنقليزية وأخطأت، أعرف أن لغتك الإنقليزية ضعيفة
وباللغة العربية نفس الشيء
التسلسل الزمني مهم، وفي ناس تلعب لعب في السيرة الذاتية
يطلع وينزل على كيفه، وهذا يخليني ما أقيس حتى عمرك المهني
ما يخليني أقيس سنة التخرج حقتك وخبرتك كم
ليش أبو عمر؟
لأن أحيانًا في ناس يصير عندها تداخل أو فترة ما صار فيها أي منجز
أنا هنا، يثير شكوكي الموضوع، وين كنت؟
يمكن لا سمح الله كنت في مكان، يمكن أنك كنت خارج البلد
فلازم أقرأك بشكل كويس، فسلسلها بشكل كويس
كمان من الأخطاء الشائعة اللي تصير، المعلومات
أيش تقصد؟
المعلومات الشخصية أحيانًا، الواحد يطير له رقم تليفون ما تعرف توصل له
آخر رقم ما يكون موجود، أو واضح
كاتب بريد إلكتروني سطر، لازم الإيميل اللي تبغاني أتواصل معك فيه
لازم يكون فيه اسمك، والمنصة اللي راح نراسلك فيها
الاسم كمان يؤثر
أنت كاتب فتى الشرقية، وللا كاتب أبو فلان، أو كاتب اسم نادي
أو أنك عاشق ما أعرف أيش
احنا موارد بشرية، لازم تبيّن...
قد تُستَبعد بسبب البريد الإلكتروني
واضح أنك جايب واحد زاحف
هذه الأخطاء يمكن ما هي مؤثرة بشكل مباشر
بس مسؤول التوظيف أحيانًا يفاضل في هذه الأمور
أنت تلقى واحد والله منظم ومرتب ودقيق، وبدون أخطاء وتسلسل
وهذا نفس الشيء، بس هذا عافس الدنيا وملخبطها فنرجع للأساس
مسؤول التوظيف يُستبعد، وينتقي الأكثر جودة
هذا لأنه يتماشى مع نزاهته المهنية
فيقول: أنا شفت هذا الشخص أرتب وأضبط
ولو قدم لي أنا في الموارد البشرية مسؤول التوظيف سيرة ذاتية بهذا الشكل
راح يكون مُلام فيها، كيف تمشي سيرة ذاتية بهذه الطريقة؟
فهو دقيق في كل معلومة موجودة في السيرة الذاتية
لأن هذه وظيفته، واحنا نقيّمه على هذا الموضوع
نقول له: أنت السيرة الذاتية اللي تجيبها ما هي كويسة
المثال اللي قلته قبل شوي، أن مقدم لي واحد بسيرة ذاتية تخصصه غير
كيف جايب لي موظف تخصصه غير المطلوب؟
فأنت فشلت في عملية استقطاب شخص حسب المواصفات اللي احنا طالبينها
في اللي يأخذون الدورات اللي على الإنترنت من مواقع
سواءً «أيدكس» أو «كورسيرا» أو غيرها
ما مدى أهمية إضافتها؟
أنا دائمًا أعزز للدورات، ولرحلة التعليم واستمرارها
ولا لها شغل بعمر، وللا بفترة معينة
طالما أنك قادر، تعلّم، طالما أنك راح تضيف لك قيمة، تعلّم
الخطأ وين؟
لا تأخذ شهادات لمجرد أنك تأخذها، وتكتبها في سيرتك الذاتية
خطأ كبير، لأنها ما ضافت لك قيمة
لو سألتك في واحدة من الدورات
قلت لي: أخذتها عبر الإنترنت، كانت مفتوحة ومريت عليها
أيش ضافت لك؟
والله كانت دورة مفتوحة وحصلت عليها، طيب ليش؟
لهذه الدرجة الوقت ما له ثمن عندك؟
لو رايح متعلم لك برنامج ومصممه، كان أحسن لك من هذا كله
الهدف الأساسي من كل الكورسات اللي تحصل عليها
أنها تعيد عليك بالمنفعة
أنها تضيف لك قيمة في المفاضلة ما بينك وما بين شخص آخر
فاليوم، إذا في أحد خريج موارد بشرية
وحاصل على شهادة «الشارم» مثلًا
أفضل من الشخص المتخرج موارد بشرية، ومش حاصل على شهادة
وهذه تعتبر شهادة ذات تقدير عالي في الموارد البشرية
فالهدف الأساسي، إضافة القيمة للسيرة الذاتية
اللي ترجّح كفتك، لما يصير في مقارنة
أبي أقول لك أن تجينا في مثلًا ثمانية
أحيانًا في ناس ترسل الناس على البريد الإلكتروني
أتوقع أنه لو بحث قليلًا عن الشركة، لعرف أن العربية مُفضّلة على الإنقليزية
فاللي يرسل السيرة ذاتية بالإنقليزية، مثلًا بالنسبة لنا يُستبعد مباشرةً
لأنه واضح ما هو عارف الشركة، واضح أنه ما بحث
لو بحث، لعرف أن إرساله باللغة الإنقليزية يضعّف مكانته
فالحين يجي، لأن الوصول إلى المقابلة الشخصي هذا لحاله تحدي
فهو ما قبل
فالسؤال: كيف يبحث الواحد يبحث عن...
وخصوصًا مثلًا لو نجي للشركات الموجودة إعلامية يمديك تعرف الكثير عنها
بس ما مدى أهمية أو أدري أنه مهم
فكيف الواحد يقدر يعرف الشركة اللي مقدم عليها أكثر؟
هل أنه يعرف ناس فيها؟
وللا أصلًا فهم الشركة غير مهم بهذه الدرجة؟
احنا عندنا مشكلة أن الشخص أحيانًا يستصعب الوصول للمعلومة
وهذا الجزء كثير ما يخطئ فيه الخريجين
مهم جدًّا أنك...
أبو عمر، المعلومة الواحدة عن الشركة تضيف لك قيمة
في طريقة كلامك معهم، الأعراف الموجودة عندهم
لما تقرأ أهدافهم، كثير من الشركات تشارك أهدافها في المواقع
تعرف أن هؤلاء الناس حساسين من الأمور اللي فيها مصداقية وثقة
لا تتكلم معهم في هذا الموضوع
واضح أنهم ينتقون بناءً على التخصصات أو النتيجة المعينة
المتخرجين مع مرتبة الشرف، وأعلى
قراءتك للشركة تبدأ تنعكس عليك، وحضورك يصير مختلف
لأنك تتكلم بلغتهم وبأسلوبهم
وهذا جزء من الذكاء، اللي أسميه الذكاء الوظيفي في المقابلة
جدًّا مهم أنك تعرف مستوى تفكير الفريق اللي قدامك
ولكن لا تتعمق كثير، لأن ممكن تتوه في العملية
ولكن كل اللي تحتاجه أنك تجمّع مجرد نقاط
عشان تقدر تدخل من أول الباب مثلما يقولون
لأن التعمق أحيانًا راح يصعب عليك الأمور
ولكن من الجيد أنك تجمع معلومات ولو بسيطة
عشان تقدر تكون في المرحلة اللي يبون يشوفونك فيه، هذا هو الهدف
أنا عندي سيرة ذاتية ممتازة، وسويت الأشياء اللي أنت قلت لي عليها،
وتخرجت، وعندي خبرة سواءً تطوعية أو تدريب
وين أقدم، وألقى الوظائف؟
نشرت هيئة الإحصاء تقرير أن الناس تجد وظائف بالدرجة الأولى
عن طريق الأهل والأصدقاء، بعدين التقديم عند أصحاب العمل مباشرة
أو الثالثة كانت المنصات المفتوحة زي «جدارات» وغيرها
فالآن وين ألقى الوظيفة، وكيف؟
هل أروح إلى المعارض اللي تسويها الجامعات أحيانًا؟
اللي هي يوم المهنة، وهل لها فائدة؟
وين أروح «لينكد إن»؟
وين تشوف المكان المثالي للتقديم على الشركات والجهات الحكومية؟
كل اللي قلته، لأن الباحث عن عمل
ما يعرف وين الجهة اللي فيها نسبة استقطاب كثيرة
فأنت كل اللي قلته، أنت باحث عن عمل، والباحث لا يكل ولا يمل
مشكلتنا أننا ما نعطي البحث عن وظيفة وقته
نكون مستعجلين ونبغى نصل
وقد تكون، البحث عن عمل انا أقول لك: ما هو شيء سهل، أبدًا
في ناس تستسهل، يقول: راح أتخرج وأتوظف، أبدًا
قد يعادل في أهميته كل الثمانية عشرة سنة اللي درستها في السابق
وين ما تلقى مكان تقدر تقدم فيه
يا أخي احنا في الفترة الأخيرة قمنا نعطي في الاستشارات
نقول له: روح بنفسك
واحد يقول لي: صار لي سنة أقدم، وما ألقى على المواقع
وأيش سويت؟
قال لي: ما كنت أقدم إلا عبر الإنترنت
خطأ كبير، روح بنفسك وجرّب
القريبين منهم بالتخصص. على سبيل المثال، مرة كلمتني ممرضة
قالت لي: أنا صار لي مدة جالسة أدور تمريض
ماني بلاقية في منطقتنا اللي ما فيها توظيف
قلت لها: مرة حصل لك وظيفة في مستشفى؟
قالت: يجيني في الأرشيف والاستقبال
قلت: هذه واحدة من الوظائف اللي قد تكون قريبة من تخصصك
بكرة، لو صار أول شاغر وظيفي لممرضة، راح يستقطبون مين؟
الموجودة
أنتِ موظفتهم، وموقعة عقد معهم، ليش نروح نجيب وحدة ثانية؟
نجيب واحدة استقبال جديد وأنت نوظفك، ليش؟
لأنها أخذت خطوة للأمام، وقربت من هدفها
فالوظائف أحيانًا ما تقدر تلقاها بس عبر الإنترنت
«لينكدإن» أو في الملتقيات، أو أحيانًا في «جدارة»
يمكن صعب، لأن عدد المتقدمين كثير
كل مكان تقدر أو تشعر أنك راح تقدر فيه تلقى فرصة، روح
استخدم كل الطرق
يمكن أنت يشدك معلومة واحدة في السيرة الذاتية
ممكن أنت في ثمانية تدور عن صانع محتوى
يومها كنت تبغى بس صانع محتوى، هذا كاتب بس صانع محتوى
رسالة، الله سبحانه وتعالى، قلت لك: أحيانًا يجيب لك الرزق من كلمة
من معرفة بسيطة، أنا والله مر علي فلان
قال لي: أنه مهتم في أن يكون نادل قهوة عندنا في ثمانية
وحابب يكون موجود من ضمن الفريق، ما تعرف
الأمور سبحان الله، فكل الطرق متاحة
سعيك أنك تصل، الله سبحانه وتعالى، يقول: اسعَ يا عبدي وأنا أسعى معك
فأنك تجلس في البيت بس تشتغل على الإنترنت، هذا واحد
اثنين، وهذه الجزئية المهمة، هنا مربط الفرس مثلما يقولون
أنت تقعد لي سنة ما تجيك وظائف
أعد حساباتك يا أخي، في عندك مشكلة، ونقص في أحد المهارات
أنت ما تتماشى مع السوق
في واحدة من المهارات اللي تتماشى مع تخصصك اليوم صارت مطلوبة
نقاط ضعفك تعرفها، وأنت تخرجت؟
أكيد يا أخي، أنا غير عبدالرحمن، أنا غير أيمن، أنا...
الجماعة توظفوا، بس هم واضح أن عندهم شيء ما هو موجود عندي
احنا مشكلتنا نكابر، يا عبد الرحمن
ونعرف أن أنا ضعيف في اللغة الإنقليزية، بس ما أبي أحد يدري
لا مو بكيفك
تخرجت، وتعرف عندك نقطة ضعف؟ اشتغل عليها
وما يكلفك شي أنك بعد التخرج تجلس 3 أو 6 شهور
أحسن من الجلسة في البيت
حاول أنك تتماشى مع السوق وتعزز من المهارات في السيرة الذاتية
لأن اللي ما يجي له اتصال بعد سنة، أنا أقول لك: عنده مشكلة
السوق أكيد فيه طلب
إي فيه، حتى لو خارج تخصصك، لا يمكن ما يجيك شيء، راجع سيرتك الذاتية
وإذا ما أنت مصدق، قدمها لأي أحد وخليه يراجع لك إياها
أنا مرت علي حالات كثيرة
أقول له: شلون تبغى يقبلونك، وأنت كاتب في اللغة الإنقليزية ضعيف
قلت له: تمزح؟
يحذفها أحسن
إي، بروح حق اللي كاتب بس لغة إنقليزية
وأنت كاتب لغة إنقليزية ضعيف
يمكن هذا أضعف منك، لأنه ما كتب إلا لغة إنقليزية
فأنت كاتب نقطة ضعف في السيرة الذاتية
هذا قياسًا بس على المهارات، في شغلات ثانية
واحد جايب معدل اثنين وكسور، مقبول!
أنت متخرج مقبول، ليش كاتبها؟
الناس مع مرتبة الشرف الثاني، ما يحطونها الحين
فهو حاط نقطة ضعف يمكن بشغلة معينة خلته يُستبعد، وما تجيه الوظيفة
فدائمًا الأساس في الحصول على الوظيفة وكثرة التقديم
وما يجيك اتصال، معناها أنت الخطوة السابقة ما كانت صحيحة
كيف أقدر أكتشف نقاط ضعفي؟
هل في مكان أو ناس أو مستشارين في جهات تساعد في هذا الموضوع؟
نقاط الضعف ما أحد يقدر يعرفها غيرك أنت، هذا بالدرجة الأولى
لا تكابر
نقاط ضعفي في السيرة الذاتية
لا، نقاط ضعفك في السيرة الذاتية هم المستشارين والمهنيين
أو إذا تعرف أحد في الموارد البشرية يراجعها لك
أو حتى أي موظف سبقك بثلاث أو أربع أو خمس سنوات
يقدر يقرأ في السيرة الذاتية كويس
ولكن أنا والله دائمًا أنصح «ما خاب من استشار»
أحيانًا العيب موجود بس ما تشوفه، لأن أنت اللي مصممها
وقد يكون واحد بس، عين واحدة تجي نشيطة
يقول لك: عندك ملاحظات عدل عليها بسيطة
ما أبغى أتكلم في هذا الموضوع كثير
بس يعلم الله أن في ناس تم تصحيح لها جزئيات في السيرة الذاتية
ما كملت الشهر، يا أبو عمر
والله ثم والله، ما كملت الشهر وحصلت على وظيفة
وأنا متأكد اللي يشوفون اللقاء هذا يعرفون أن في لنا زملاء
في مساحات تويتر دائمًا نفتح مراجعة سيرة ذاتية، نتكلم مع الناس بالآلاف
واحنا مجموعة بالآلآف نراجع سيرة ذاتية
تجي لنا إشادات بعدها بأسبوع، ففي كان خلل، سبحان الله
وهذا أنا أقول لك في ناس راح تعلّق على الكلام اللي أنا بقوله الآن
فعلًا في أمور كثيرة تصلحت في سير ذاتية
جزئيات صغيرة تعدلت، والأمور فُتحت
سبحان الله
إي والله
أنا أتوقع أول مرة أنتبه للفكرة اللي تقولها
كيف ينظر لها موظف الموارد البشرية؟ إذا فهمت أنه جالس يُصفي فعلًا
فتتغير المعادلة
كيف أخلي ورقتي أو سيرتي الذاتية غير قابلة للتصفية، أو تتصفى بشكل إيجابي؟
أول شيء، إذا كانت واضحة وخطوطها واضحة، ومرتبة كويس
عوامل صغيرة بس، لأن موظف الموارد البشرية ينظر إلى جزئيات
وكلمات مفتاحية هو يبحث عنها
وإذا تجيه 500-600 هو على السريع
أقول لك: هو في الأصل يستبعدك
هو جالس يدور شيء يخليه يشيلك
أقول لك: هو في الأصل قاعد يتصيد
حط لي تاريخ غلط، شيله
كاتب لي 2020 وتحت كاتب 1434
واضح أن أنت ملخبط الأمور، ماني فاضي
استبعد، راح يجيب زبدة الزبد، ليش؟
لأن في ناس تصفي وراءه، أنا راح يجيب لي السير الذاتية
ولو شفت فيه مشكلة أنت مو شايف شغلك
فيبدأ يدقق مرة واثنين وثلاثة
وبعدما يفرز ويطلع الخلاصة، يعصرها مرة ثانية
يصير التدقيق الثاني فهي، أبو عمر، فلاتر
في فلتر أول: للأغلاط الصغيرة، الفلتر الثاني: التخصصات
الفلتر الثالث: قبل لا يروح هناك
إذا راح للمدراء، راح تصير عليه مشكلة هو
تسمح لي قصة صغيرة
تفضل
احنا مرة واحدة من السير الذاتية ما فلتر
مش التخصص، ما صفى أن الشخص ما كان عنده مهارة كنا محتاجينها
وصلتنا، وما انتبهنا، وجاءنا في المقابلة الشخصية، وتوظف
والله العظيم
أمه داعية له
إن شاء الله يشوفني، وتوظف، بعد فترة جاءنا تدقيق
يصير في تدقيق عشان ننظم، الحوكمة تعرف يجي عليك مفتش
يقول: طلعوا لي، ويأخذ عشوائيًّا عقود مع الطلبات
قال: هذا شلون توظف وهو ينقصه المهارة؟
أيش كانت المهارة؟
اللغة الإنقليزية
ووظيفته؟
وظيفته إداري عندنا في السكرتارية
فكان أنه ما يجيد اللغة الإنقليزية؟
مش المستوى اللي نبغاه، وتوظف
الغريب في الموضوع أن احنا ما اكتشفنا خلال الستة شهور الأولى
مشى الرجل، وعدّى مرحلة التجربة
صار طبعًا في لجنة، وفُتح فيه تحقيق؛ هو مش مشكلة كبيرة
بس فُتح تحقيق عشان يضمنون النزاهة، لأن هذا واضح أنه مر بدون ما أحد ينتبه
فأول شيء تحققوا أنه عن طريق الخطأ
ولكن، سبحان الله، الرجل طلع فلتة زمانه، هو إلى الحين موظف
وجيت قلت له، لأن لازم نبلغه
جزء من النزاهة عشان يعرف أنت عليك العين
ومطلوب منك تجتهد أكثر، وهذه فرصة
لا ينتهي عقد السنة إلا أنت تكون...
حسّنت من نفسك
إي، فجبناه وتكلمنا وإياه
وقلنا له: احنا ما أدري مين داعي لك هذاك اليوم
الوالدة هي مطلعة لك، ومتصدق شكلك هذيك الليلة، والله شيء غريب
سبحان الله
شيء غريب، فمن الأخطاء اللي تصير تكون كوارثها كبيرة وفادحة
هذا طلع كويس، لك أن تتخيل أنه ما طلع كويس
خليك منه هو أو احنا، احنا راح نأخذ إنذار بيعطونا وبتمشي
تخيل تقول له: راح نمشيك بعد ثلاثة الأشهر
مصيبة
تأثمنا فيه وكسرنا نفسه وأحبطناه
والله موقف صعب، لو ما كان هو الشخص المناسب في المكان المناسب
فلذا موظف الموارد البشرية مهم أن...
لازم تعصرها عصار عشان ما يصير...
ما أحد يجي بعدين يحقق معك
بالضبط
مش بس يحقق معي، ولا تظلم هذا الرجل المسكين
هذا ممكن يكون طالع من وظيفة
قدم استقالة، وترك وظيفة عشان يجي يتوظف
فتكبر كرة الجليد إلى أن تكبر المشكلة
احنا لو لم يتفهم المدقق معنا أن الشخص عدّا بمحض الصدفة
وخطأنا طبعًا أن احنا ما اننتبهنا، وللا كان قال: لازم يمشي وتعوضونه
طيب نعوضه، بس ما راح يقدر يرجع لوظيفته
فالدقة مطلوبة مع مسؤول التوظيف
أغلب الوظائف ما يُعلن عنها
وينتهي التوظيف وتتم العملية عن طريق أصدقاء أو معارف وخلافه
كيف أقدر أكون علاقات، وأنا لسه ما توظفت؟
سؤال حلو
شوف من أيام الجامعة ، أنا مرّ علي أمثلة كثير
توظّفوا بسبب العلاقات أيام الجامعة
في أعمال تطوعية كثير تصير في الجامعة خارج الحرم الجامعي
مؤتمرات ومنتديات وأعمال تطوعية كثيرة
جمعيات خيرية يروحون يساهمون فيها
تبدأ شبكة العمل الخاصة بك تتوسع
من هذه المؤتمرات الكبيرة اللي تصير
أحيانًا أنت تكون مشارك في فعالية من الفعاليات
تتعرف لك على ثلاثة أو أربعة، قطعًا راح تطلع بصداقات جديدة
فتبدأ تنتشر، والله في شخص اسمه «خالد عبدالرحمن»
لأنه على اسم الممثل، خرّيج جامعة البترول
والله أنا أحب أقول بالأسامي لأنه يستحق التقدير
قبل أن يتخرج بسنتين صار يعرف في الموارد البشرية أكثر من مما أعرف أنا
ويحضر عندنا الملتقيات
كنت أشوفه في «توست ماستر» موجود، وأشوفه يسأل عن كتب الإدارة
بعدما تخرج قابلته في مكان
قال لي: يعلم الله أن علاقاتي هي اللي وظفتني بعدما...
قال: أنا ما أعرف أحد، كنت في الجامعة
آخر سنتين، اشتغلت على علاقات وأنشطة
وبدأت أنا أستضيف، بدأ هو يسوي مؤتمرات
يقول: بدأت أجمع الطلاب، وسوى برنامج اسمه «بترولي» أعتقد
وقاموا يجيبون خبراء ويسوون حاجة يسمونها مقابلات شخصية وهمية
يسوون مقابلات شخصية حق اللي راح يتخرجون، وهو كان يقود العملية
صار يعرف شباب في الموارد البشرية، ويخدم الطلاب الموجودين
فوسّع دائرة العلاقات حسب كلامه لي بعدما تخرج
قال لي: أنا ما جلست شهر، واشتغلت في وظيفة
صحيح أنها ما كانت اللي أطمح فيه، بس كانت بداية بالنسبة لي مرة موفقة
فتقدر تنشئ العلاقات من أيام الجامعة من خلال المحافل والمنتديات والمؤتمرات
المشاركة مع المجتمع تخليك تعرف كثير
أيش الفرق بين العلاقات والواسطة؟
كبير
والله؟
والله كبير واجد
أيش الفرق؟
ممتاز، أن نوضح الفرق عشان نفهّم الغير أن في تضارب في الموضوع
نبدأ بالواسطة
الواسطة هي أنك تحصل على الوظيفة وتتخطى كل الصعاب والعقبات
وقد تتخطى حتى الجدارة، ممكن ما تكون جدير في الوظيفة
وممكن تصل حتى إلى مستوى عالي في الوظيفة بدون أنت ما تستحق
ما أنت أمورك مسلّكة
وهذول النوعية اللي يصلون لهذا المكان
دائمًا بيئات العمل اللي هم فيها ما هي بيئة كويسة
لأنه بكل حال من الأحوال يشوف الناس اللي تحته أفضل منه
ما الأكفّاء وين موجودين؟ هم اللي جاءوا بالسلّم الوظيفي
فصاروا أصحاب كفؤ في مناصبهم يعرفون كل شيء
ما التسلسل يعطيك قوة، والقوة من وين تجي؟
من المعرفة، اسمها قوة المعرفة
الأخ جاء إلى الدفة بالطريق...
الباراشوت
إي، فهذا ما توظف بالكفاءة، وما وقف عند حواجز
وما تصفى كويس، وصل إلى المنصة
نجي للعلاقات، أنا اليوم، أبو عمر جاءني
قال لي: أنا عندي «إكس» من الموظفين متخرج بمعدل عالي
ممتاز في الموارد البشرية
وحاصل على شهادتين، وعنده خبرة قليلة في منصات الموارد البشرية
وأعتقد أنه راح يكون مكسب لكم
هذه شهادة مختومة من شخص له اعتبار
أنا لأنك شخصية اعتبارية، وتربطني فيك علاقة
نرجع للعلاقات، راح أستدعي الشخص وراح أصفّيه
كل اللي أنت سويته أنك وصلته إلى الباب
للمقابلة الشخصية
إي، أوصلته إلى الباب، الآن هو راح يقدر يفتح الباب وللا لا؟
جيبوا سيرته الذاتية، زي ما قال أبو عمر، الرجل شكله كويس
الفلتر الثاني: المقابلة الشخصية
هنا تجي التصفية الأساسية اللي هي قياس الجدارة بناءً على السيرة
احنا نقيس جدارة الشخص بالوظيفة بناءً على السيرة والمقابلة الشخصية
وهنا تجي المطابقة
هل الشخص فعلًا اللي في السيرة، وللا مسلكها وجايب له سيرة؟
فتجي المطابقة عليه
هل هو فعلًا الشخص المعتبر الموجود في السيرة
واللي تكلم عنه أبو عمر وللا لا؟
إذا كان جيد وعدّا، وجاب نتيجة جيدة مقارنةً في المتقدمين
ما أُعطِيته أي شيء، وما أعطيته أي زيادة، وما دفيته
وحقق النتيجة المطلوبة خمسة من خمسة
أو جاب ثلاثة من خمسة، والبقية جابوها اثنين فهو جدير
لأن إذا توظف في مكان ما يستحقه قطعًا ما راح ينجح
مو بس ما راح ينجح، راح يفشل ويخلي المجموعة اللي معه تفشل، هذا واحد
اثنين: ممكن هذا يسوي لك مشاكل بعدين
أو ممكن أنه ينضغط في العمل، ويقول لك: أنا بمشي ما تحملت
فالمشكلة أن في ناس تخلط ما بين الواسطة والعلاقة
العلاقات المهنية اللي أراها صراحة...
ليش احنا نوظف عن طريق العلاقة؟
ليش يقول لك: ما توظف عن طريق...؟
رحلة التوظيف طويلة ومتعبة
وممكن أن يصل إلى الأخير، وتعطيه عقد، يقول لك: ما أبغاه
فتعبتنا وجبناك وقابلناك
فكلمة أو توصية واحدة، جاءت من شخص صاحب علاقة وثقة
لازم ثقة، مو بأي واحد يكلمك تروح تقول له: إي جيبه
وفرت علي فرز آلاف السير الذاتية
وفرت علي الترشيح للمقابلة الشخصية، وهذا ممكن يأخذ له شهر
أنا ممكن في أول ثلاثة أيام أستدعيه وأجيبه
أقول له: سوي اختبار القبول، إذا عديته راح تدخل مقابلة شخصية
تتكلم عن توفير في الوقت بنسبة 90%
وإذا توظف وكان جدير بكرة أنا راح أتصل عليك، أبو عمر ما عندك واحد زيه؟
والله العظيم
في مجموعة الموارد البشرية كذا يصير
خلاص عندي الرجل هذا ينتقي الأشخاص بعناية
فتصير أنت واحد من مصادرنا، اللي نقدر نوظف فيها
وفي الغالب، يكون الشخص جدير بالتوظيف
أنه فعلًا كان الشخص المناسب في المكان المناسب
وأنا وظفت ناس كذا
ممتاز
الحين أبو عبدالعزيز، نجي للموضوع الأهم
أنا وصلت للمقابلة الشخصية، شلون أستعد لها؟
قبل عشر سنوات ما كان في شيء يسمى استعداد للمقابلة الشخصية
يدقون عليك وتروح، اليوم بسبب الفشل اللي يصير
بسبب كثرة الفشل، أنا أسميه، في المقابلة الشخصية
المنافسة صارت قوية، وصاروا الناس ما هم عارفين كيف يكونون جاهزين فيها
في المقابلة الشخصية
فمن كثرة أن الناس ما تجتاز، صاروا الناس يقول لك: كيف؟
وساعدونا نستعد للمقابلة الشخصية
فمن الجيد أن الواحد يستعد
الآن أنا سأحضر المقابلة الشخصية
هل الاستعداد للمقابلة الشخصية مجرد ما يوصلني اتصال، أبدأ أستعد؟
هو هذا الغلط الكبير اللي يصير في المقابلة الشخصية
لأن استعدادك للمقابلة الشخصية ممكن يصير من بعد التخرج
أنت لازم تعرف أيش راح تسوي في مقابلتك الشخصية
لازم تعرف كيف تحضّر وتستعد
لأن احنا في المقابلة الشخصية نقيس حاجتين مهمين
عفوًا، ثلاث
الأولى، مقدار الثقة
الثقة ما تجي إلا لما يكون الشخص مجهز ومستعد
وجاي للامتحان وهو يعرف أن ما في سؤال راح يمر عليه ماراح يجاوب عليه
وكمان زيادة على كذا راح يتكلم وما راح يسكت، ويهتز ويتأتئ، واثق
وهذا القياس مهم جدًّا
الإيجابية مهمة في المقابلة الشخصية
وإذا كنت متخوف، وما أنت مستعد كويس
راح تبان عليك السلبية قطعًا، ما فيها كلام
الحاجة الثالثة هي الأمور الشخصية
احنا في المقابلة الشخصية نقيسك مهاريًّا وشخصيًّا
بس ما أقدر أقيس سلوكك وكيف راح...
إلا بعد ما تتوظف، فأبدأ أشوف الشخص، والله العظيم أنه يتجاوب بسرعة
فعلًا إيجابي لما نسلب منه شيء من حقوقه
يتقبل النقد
يتقبل أنه أنت يمكن ما تكون الشخص، مرن في التعامل
مستعد حتى لما نطلع في عيوب في المقابلة الشخصية
يقول لك: عادي هذه وجهة نظر وأحترمها، في ناس ما..
من تبدأ تنقد عليه في المقابلة الشخصية، يفور
فهو مش مستعد للمقابلة الشخصية
من هنا، نقول أن الشخص لازم يكون محضر كويس
لكل الأسئلة المُتوقّع أنها تجي لك في المقابلة الشخصية
ومنها لما أجي أتكلم أسألك: عرّف عن نفسك؟
لا يمكن أن أنت ما تعرف نفسك كويس
ولازم لما تُعرّف عن نفسك، يكون جزء كبير من هذا الكلام
يصب في المسمّى الوظيفي اللي أنت مقدم عليه
ما هو كل تعريف تعريف
ممكن تعرف باسمك وتخصصك، وتقول: أنا تخرجت في السنة الفلانية وتسكت
بس ممكن توسّع الدائرة شوي
أنت جاي تشتغل في محاسبة مثلًا
أنا اسمي فلان الفلاني، تخرجت من جامعة «الملك سعود»
تخصص محاسبة
وحصلت على شهادة المحاسبين السعوديين في عام كذا
شوف شلون تأخذ الجذب من عندهم، وتصبّ في المسمّى الوظيفي
وحصلت على دورة في «المايكروسوفت أوفس، إكسل» باحترافية
وهذه الشهادة أعطتني أريحية في إنجاز المهام
وواحدة من أهم المنجزات اللي اشتغلت عليها
اللي هي مشروع التخرج اللي ساعدني أني أطوّر في المحاسبة
تعريف
ممتاز
بعدما يخلص، احنا نصفق له، مستعد وواضح، ومركز على نقاط القوة
فهذه جزئية مهمّة
«أيمن» مركز عشان يمكن تقدم على وظيفة ثانية؟
تجي لما نسألك عن خبراتك
يمكن الشخص يكون عنده خبرات كويسة، ويمكن لا
بس لازم تحضّر أنك تقول يا خبراتك، راح تتكلم عن الجامعة؟
أو تتكلم عن الخبرات اللي أخذتها قبل الوظيفة هذه؟
كمان لازم تتكلم عن الخبرات اللي تعزز من موقفك
أنت جاي تكشر عن أنيابك اليوم
أنت جاي تقول أن أنا أحسن واحد راح تختارونه في هذه الوظيفة
فلما تحدد لك نقاط قوة تتماشى مع المسمّى الوظيفي
أنت قاعد تحطهم في الإطار، ما تبغى تشتتهم وتطلعهم
ومجهّز كل نقطة راح تتكلم عنها بأريحية
راح يسألونك يمكن عن نقاط ضعفك
ما في أحد ما عنده نقاط ضعف
ولكن هُم الهدف من أنهم يسألونك عن نقاط ضعفك
هل أنت تعرفها أوّل؟
إذا كنت تعرفها، هل كان عندك خطة لتطويرها أو تتجاوزها؟ بدأت؟
يمكن ما بدأت، ما بعد لقيت فرصة
بس أنا عندي نقطة، في واحد يقول خمس نقاط
ما أحد قال لك: قُل خمس نقاط
قل لنا: نقاط ضعفك واحدة أو اثنتين يعني
والله أنا قاعد أطور في اللغة الإنقليزية بشكل كويس
والحمد لله بدأت وأنا متحسن
ينقصني شوية بعض المهارات الناعمة اللي المفروض
تكون متواجدة في هذا التخصص خصوصًا...
فأنت عارف أيش جاي تقول، ومحضّر أصلًا، ولا أنت متفاجئ
متى يبدأ يقل اجتيازك للمقابلة الشخصية؟
لما تُسأل أسئلة بديهية، وهم يعتقدون أنك محضّر للإجابة
أو يسألونك أسئلة في تخصصك اللي أنت جاي مقدّم عليه
وما أنت قادر تجاوب
فأنت يمكن ما فشلت في المقابلة الشخصية
يمكن اجتزت بنسبة معينة، وخلاص جبت الهدف
بس في واحد بعدك جاي
يمكن يكون استعداده أفضل منك، ويمكن تكون إجاباته مقنعة
ممكن تكون إنجازاته اللي تكلّم عنها بشكل إيجابي
أكثر من اللي أنت كنت تتكلم عنه
فالثقة والإيجابية وشخصيتك الحاضرة في المقابلة الشخصية
أهم ثلاث عناصر تجعلك تجتاز المقابلة الشخصية
وهذا ما يجي إلا قبل التحضير المسبق
حسنًا، أتوقع أن كل الناس اللي يدخلون المقابلة يكونوا مرتبكين
ما مدى إدراككم لهذا الإرتباك، وكيف تتعاملون معه؟
والله أنا أحب الأسئلة الموجّهة
هذا سؤال موجّه لنا احنا كموارد بشرية تقصد
بطبيعة الإنسان، وهذه احنا تعلمناها كنت أقولها كثير في «توست ماستر»
اللي يدخلون «توست ماستر» يتكلمون أمام مجموعة كبيرة
أول ما تتكلم أمام مجموعة ما تسمعهم، تسمع نفسك
ومرتبك، وتبدأ تتعرق، وهذه أمور نفسية بحتة
ولأني درست شوي أنا في علم الاجتماع هذا الموضوع
جزء من شخصية الإنسان لمّا يواجه الجمهور يرتبك
لمّا الموارد البشرية يعتدّون بهذا الجانب
وظيفتك أن تساعد الشخص أن يتكلم، وظيفتك أنك تخلي الشخص...
أحيانًا تبيّن علينا الملامح، ومتوقعين أصلًا
خصوصًا الآن لما صار توظيف السيدات أكثر وحتى في الرجال
السيدات يرتبكون أكثر أحيانًا، ما هو كثير
ولكن دوري أنا اليوم من لما أشعر بهذا الشخص أنه فعلًا مرتبك
لازم أطلع زي ما نسميه احنا خارج الصندوق
لازم الأسئلة تكون أسئلة غير مباشرة بحيث أن أنا...
كيف كان يومك؟
تريّحه
كيف كان يومك؟ يبيّن عليه
أمس نمت كويس، وجبت لك قهوة وللا نجيب لك؟
فيبدأ هو يهدأ
أنا عطيته، لأنه شوف التصرفات، لكل فعل ردة فعل
هو لما يشوفني أنا مبسوط ومرتاح راح ينعكس عليه
في بعضهم...
احنا حتى في لبسنا في المقابلة الشخصية يؤثر
أحيانًا نكون مرسّمين وأحيانًا نجي كذا
فهو يقول: لا شكلهم حبايب الجماعة، أمورهم طيبة ويتقبل منهم
في جزئيات صغيرة تؤثر في المقابلة الشخصية
دائمًا أنا أقول أن أحيانًا، وهذه رسالة للموارد البشرية
لما أحيانًا الشخص يكون ممتاز، وجدير بالوظيفة
واحنا عارفين أنه عنده مشكلة، بس أنه يتكلم
وأنه تكون هذه من المقابلات الشخصية الجديدة عليه
لا تكمل معه المقابلة الشخصية
أيش تسوي؟
مرره، قُل له: روح، تبي أرتب لك يوم ثاني؟
ممكن يطلع يرتاح شوي، ممكن المكان ما هو عاجبه
ممكن التكييف مؤثر عليه
في فيسيولوجيات وجزئيات صغيرة تؤثر على الشخص
في بعض الموارد البشرية يخطئون أحيانًا
في لجنة المقابلة الشخصية احنا نسميه
أنت جاي تسوي مقابلة شخصية لشخص، ومقابلينه سبعة
هذا أمر، أنا لو كنت خائف، ودخلت على سبعة
بالنسبة لي أنا...
خلاص
لجنة المقابلة الشخصية المفروض ما يتجاوز ثلاثة، وكثير على الشخص
لأن الحديث دائمًا أنت تحتاج منه يكون عنده تواصل بصري كثير
فيطالع هذا ويطالع هذا، وهذا سؤال من هنا، وهذا سؤال من هنا
ويتأثر فينا أنت أحيانًا تسوي له كذا، وأحيانًا تسوي له
أنت قضيت عليه، فلا يتجاوز العدد
أنا أشوف أن مهمة فريق الموارد البشرية
أنه ينجح يطلّع أفضل ما هو موجود عند هذا الشخص
وعندما يرتاح راح يبدأ ينفلت لك
أنت اللي بتقول له: خلاص تكفى اسكت
قبلناك بس..
هنا أنا أعتبر نفسي أني نجحت في المقابلة الشخصية
عادي يجتاز المقابلة الشخصية
أو ما يجتازها بناءً على العلامات اللي نعطيها، هذا أمر ثاني
بس مجرد ما خليته ينطلق، ويرتاح قبل المقابلة الشخصية
أنا أعتبر هذا هو أساس نجاح المقابلة الشخصية
أيش العلامات اللي تقيسون عليها؟
تقصد في اجتياز المقابلة الشخصية؟
إي، أنت تقول: عندكم هدف، وفي علامة معينة، بناءً على أيش؟
أحيانًا المقابلات الشخصية تجي بنوعين، وأحيانًا النوعين في نوع واحد
أحيانًا التخصصية، المحاسبة راح يقابله محاسب
ما له شغل، الموارد البشرية هنا ما تقرر إلا أنه اجتاز المقابلة الأولى
ولكن، في مقابلات تفصيلية دقيقة في التخصص نفسه
هذه خلها على جنب
هذه لها علامات مهمة جدًّا، ما أخليها على جنب لازم أوضح
أبغى أقول للشخص: أن إذا ما كنت محضر لتخصصك
ما راح تجيب العلامة الأهم في المقابلة الشخصية
لما أسألك في المصروفات والميزانيات
أنت محاسب، إذا ما تعرف تجاوب
وتقول لي: أن في دَين وائتمان وما أعرف أيش
يعرف هذه التفاصيل الدقيقة
ما راح تتحول أصلًا حتى للمقابلة الثانية
فهذه جزئية لازم تحضّر لها بشكل كويس
نجي لنا احنا
أنا قلت: خليها على جنب، لأنها بديهية
إذا ما يفهم في تخصصه فمن الأحرى أنه بيمشي
يا ليت أنها بديهية، لأن في ناس...
قلت لك أنا في البداية: من القنبلة اللي أنا أعتبرها
من الصدمات اللي تجينا أن الشخص يخطأ في معلومات أساسية في تخصصه
ممكن ما يخطأ، ممكن ينسى، مرّ عليه فترة بعد التخرج
هذا ما يمنع أنك تراجع سيرتك الذاتية
أنت كاتب كل شيء فيها، وكاتب أنك جيد فيها
حضّر كويس عشان ما تُسأل سؤال، وخطأ جزئية صغيرة بسيطة
لأن في بعض الأسئلة يسمونها أسئلة الألغاز في التخصص نفسه
فيعطيك معادلة أو لغز معين يبغاك تجاوب عليه
فلازم تكون محضّر جاهز
نجي لنا احنا
زي ماقلت لك: احنا ما نقيس في المقابلة الشخصية الأمور السلوكية
لأن السلوكيات ما تبين، بس احنا نقيس الأمور الشخصية
في أمور كثيرة نقيس فيها المصداقية والنزاهة والأمانة المهنية
ممكن نقول له: أنت لو مر عليك أحد الموظفين
واكتشفت أنه كسر جزء موجود على المكتب، وأخذه وخبأه، أيش تتصرّف؟
يقول لك: بروح أقول له: أنت كسرت هذا الشيء، وجيب بداله
جزئيات صغيرة، وفي أسئلة صغيرة نكتشف أنه حريص على ممتلكات الشركة
أنت لو مر عليك، أنت في قسم المشتريات اليوم
ومر عليك أحد من أقربائك، وقال لك: أن احنا نبيع السلعة هذه
وأنت في قسم المشتريات، أرخص من اللي أنت تشتريها
تقول: والله بجيبها، أنا أعرف أن عندك مشكلة في تعارض المصالح
المفروض أنك ترفع وتتكلم، وتقول: أبلّغ الإدارة
لأن هذا أحد أقربائي، وأنت وقعت
ولازم تعرف أن أي شيء له علاقة بالأقارب لازم أن...
فأنا أبدأ أقيس أن الشخص عنده مشكلة ثقة، ما نقدر نثق فيه
ففي جزئيات وأسئلة صغيرة غير مباشرة
بس تؤثر بشكل كبير في المقابلة الشخصية
وهذه من الأسئلة زي ما قلت لك
في البداية احنا ما نقيس إلا الأمانة المهنية والنزاهة
هذه الجزئية مهمة
أن شخص يستطيع يعمل في مجموعة، ويتقبل النقد والاختلاف
خصوصًا أنت تعرف، أبو عمر، أن في مجتمعنا في كثير من العلاقات
في علاقات شخصية، وزمالة، ومهنية
العلاقات المهنية تصنف من أكثر العلاقات المعقدة في مجتمعنا وحياتنا
والسبب أن احنا مختلفين
أنا وأنت من مناطق مختلفة، مذاهبنا وجنسياتنا مختلفة
يمكن أنت...، ديننا مختلف، أنت ممكن تشتغل مع ناس ما هم من دينك
فلازم تبين أنك، واحنا نسأل بعض الأسئلة
لازم أنت متقبل هذا الاختلاف، وإذا ما كنت متقبل
لا يمكن أنك تعيش مع المجموعة
ففي بعض الأسئلة تبين أنك شخص مرن
وما عندك مشكلة مع الاختلاف و الاندماج
لأن الحين صار في اختلاط ما بين الجنسين
إذا أنت مو متقبل، ويمكن يجي له سؤال عابر
يقول لك: أنا ما أشتغل في مكاتب فيها سيدات
كويس، احنا عندنا مكاتب ما فيها سيدات، بس برة الشركة، ما عندنا هنا
فأنت تعرف هذا شخص لا يتقبل الاختلاف، هذا واحد
اثنين...
مو بالضرورة، بس ممكن الشركة فعلًا ما عندها
في شركات يكون في عندها قسمين مختلفين، وفي شركات ما عندها
فأنا كشركة ما عندي
إي، أقول لك: ممكن، حتى لو ما عندي، احنا صرنا مندمجين
عندنا أنظمة وقوانين تحكم هذه الأمور، مو معناها أن احنا نشتغل مع بعض
معناها أن في مشكلة، بس احنا نجتمع ونجلس مع بعض
عندهم مكان ومصلّى وكل شيء خاص فيهم
بس في عملنا مع بعض، لازم نكون متواجدين، هو ما راح يتقبل هذا الوضع
هذه جزئيات نقيس عليها
كمان من الأمور اللي نقيس عليها، أن أحيانًا، الشخص ما هو مرن
لما نقول له: لو حصلت عندنا أزمة في نوبة آخر الليل، أيش راح تسوي؟
يقول: والله إذا كنت صاحي، راح أجي وإذا ما كانت صاحي، لا كذا مشكلة
أو صارت عندنا مشكلة، واحنا شغالين اليوم
دوامنا ينتهي الساعة 16:00
وبينت عندنا مشكلة لازم تُحل بعد الساعة 16:00
والله أنا أحب أشتغل فقط ثماني ساعات
احنا الحين نشوف في ناس ما ترجع البيت وقت الأزمات إلى اليوم الثاني
وهذا يعطيك انطباع أن الشخص مرن، ويتقبل الصدمات
ويعرف يحل المشاكل
فهذه الجزئيات، كمان تُقاس في المقابلة الشخصية
هذا لا يعني أنكم تقولون: أنه أبغاه يشتغل أربع وعشرين ساعة طول الحياة
لا
بس أن وقت الأزمات تختلف الحالات
السؤال إي، مش السؤال أنك تشتغل أربع وعشرين أو اثنا عشر ساعة
السؤال، أنت في وقت الأزمات، كيف تتعامل معها؟
ففي أمور زي ما قلت لك، غير مباشرة، بس ترمي في مكان معين
ممتاز، أنت قلت قبل شوي: العلاقات، فودي أخذها على جزئين
كيف الشكل المثالي لعلاقتي...؟
الآن توظفت، وأديت
كيف تكون علاقتي مع زملائي، وهل هي علاقة عمل أو صداقة؟
وأيش الإطار المنطقي والطبيعي لها؟
كنت أتكلم معك عن العلاقات المهنية، هي معقدة كثير
لأن احنا مختلفين بطبيعتنا، ونحتاج نتقبل هذا الاختلاف
العلاقات المهنية ممكن يكون لها حدود وسقف معين
الشخص يحط له مسافات
أنا هذا حدودي، ما أحب أتجاوز، ولا أحب أحد يتجاوز علي
وهذا هو حدود الزمالة المهنية من نطلع من برة العمل
احنا تقريبًا، انتهى كل شيء بيننا، ونرجع لليوم الثاني
ولكن في بعض العلاقات يصير في توافق أفكار
ويصير في تقارب سنّي ما بيننا
يصير في اهتمامات وهوايات عندنا تجمعنا مع بعض
فمع مرور الأيام تتحول هذه الزمالة إلى صداقة كبيرة
أنا كثير تربطني علاقات صداقة ومش زملاء، أكثر من زملاء
أكثر من إخواني اليوم هم
أثّر علينا حتى في بيوتنا وعوائلنا، احنا أطفالنا صاروا قد بعض
فكنا نطلع مع بعض نتمشى
إضافةً لكذا، زوجاتنا صار بينهم علاقات
تعرف لما أهلك في البيت يشوفون أنك قريب من شخص
يتبادلون الهدايا في المواليد، في رمضان يتبادلون السفر
والله في وجبة معينة أهل الشمال يحبونها أهل الحساء، النقصة نسميها
فتتطور العلاقة، وتبقى حتى بعد الرحلة المهنية
وهذه موجودة، وأنا عشتها ولي زملائي كثير
وأعرف ناس لهم تجارب كثير
ولهم ملتقيات تصير حتى بعد الدوام
وحتى لما يتفرقون في ملتقيات تجمعهم وتواصل
صارت الحياة أسهل الآن، ولكن أنت من يحدد هذا الشيء
كيف أكسب زملائي وأنا موظف جديد؟
والله أحب هذا السؤال كثير
عشان تكسب الزملاء لازم يكون عندك بعض المهارات
وأنا أقيسها على المهارات الناعمة
اللي تصير عند الشخص عشان يكسب أصدقاء
بطبيعة الحال، أنت لما تدخل أي منظومة جديدة
أو أي بيئة عمل جديدة راح يقيسون مدى مرونتك، وتقبلك لهم
والاختلاط والاندماج معهم
هذا الشيء يحتاج أول شيء إحترام
إذا أظهرت الاحترام لزملاء العمل، فعل وردة فعل
أنت محترم، احنا نحترمك، أنت راح تتجاوز ما أحد راح يقرب منك
فالاحترام مطلوب في بيئات العمل عشان تقدر تبني علاقات مرة كويسة
هذا أول أساس
احنا عندنا مبدأ في الشركة، أول ما تدخل باب الشركة تقرأه
اسمه: أظهِر الاحترام، مش تحترم، بل أظهِر هذا الاحترام
لازم نشوفه في كل تصرفاتك اليومية
وهذا مبدأ كبير محطوط على البوابة أول ما تدخل
الشيء الثاني، وهذه واحدة من أكثر المهارات الناعمة اللي نفقدها
الاهتمام، أني أهتم بزميل العمل، إذا عندي مهارة كويسة أعلّمه
وإذا هو عنده مهارة كويسة، يعلّمني
الأخذ والعطاء في بناء العلاقات المهنية ممتازة، هذا واحد
اثنين: أن احنا نتبادل الخبرات السابقة والجديدة
أنت تعرف أحيانًا في بيئات العمل كل واحد يصير مرجع في جزئية معينة
تبي واحد في صناعة المحتوى، أدق واحد
تبي واحد في التقديم، أبو عمر، هو أحسن واحد معروف في التقديم
تبي واحد في التواصل والعلاقات «أيمن» فكل واحد مرجع
أنا أحتاجك اليوم، أنا جيت موظف جديد أبغاك...
وفي العلاقات، والله عندي موظف هو اللي يقدر يدربك
أنا اليوم جاي من بيئة ثانية، أنا أعرف علاقات في منطقة أنت ما تعرفها
أيش رأيك أن أنت تستفيد وأنا أستفيد؟
فالعطاء والاهتمام وتبادل الخبرات هذا جدًّا مهم
في جزئية أبي أركز عليها على الاهتمام
أحيانًا بعض الموظفين يمرون بظروف خارج العمل
يبدأوا الشباب بداخل العمل يهتمون فيه
أنت ارتاح، احنا راح نغطيك
أنت تحتاج أن احنا نساعدك، وأنت في مشكلتك، راح نجي ندعمك
أنت تحتاج أن أحد يتواصل معك باستمرار؟
جزئية الاهتمام، وهذه واحدة من اللي قرأتها في كتب كثيرة في علوم الإدارة
أن بناء العلاقات في بيئة العمل تحتاج اهتمام وعطاء
حط تحتها خطين
كثيرين بعض الموظفين، يجلس على مكتبه من يدخل الساعة الثمانية ويطلع
ولا يعرف ولا يعطي، وإذا جئت تتكلم معه أنا مشغول
هذا حكم على نفسه أنه قليل العلاقات، وما يقدر يروح لبعيد
وفي ناس تتسم عليهم أن الشخص تبي تأخذ
في علامات معينة في بعض الأقسام
لما يقول لك: أنا أبغى أحل مشكلة عندي في الموارد البشرية
يقول لك: روح حق «عبدالله» ما أحد بيحلها لك إلا هو
يا أخي حقين الموارد البشرية هؤلاء ما تدخل عليهم إلا يسووا لك السالفة...
هذه شفناها حتى في المراجعات الحكومية
تروح أحيانًا حق شخص، يقول لك: تبي تحل مشكلتك ادخل على فلان
نعرفها هذه، فالأشخاص اللي يتبادلون العطاء
والاهتمام هم اللي يقدرون يبنون علاقات إيجابية في بيئة العمل
أول شيء كيف علاقاتكم في ثمانية؟
مشربكة والله
كلها هواش وللا؟
مشكلة
يبغى لكم دورة مهارات ناعمة
قلت: أن زملاء ممكن يهتمون لزميلهم خارج العمل
صحيح
هل الشركة المفترض أنها تهتم لموظفها خارج نطاق العمل؟
شوف، اهتمام الشركة بموظفينها خارج العمل
يحكمها شغلات كثيرة، إذا كان هذا الشيء موجود
في الرؤية وأهداف الشركة أن احنا نهتم بموظفيننا
أو احنا الشعارات اللي تصير، احنا عائلة واحدة مثلًا
نعم لأن اهتمامنا في موظفنا، هذا يعزز الولاء والإنتاجية والاستمرارية عنده
مو في تسرب وظيفي
أحيانًا الواحد يقول لك أنا الشركة وقفت معي في أماكن وأزمات
لا يمكن أستغني عنها بأي شكل من الأشكال
ممكن أحيانًا الشركة تمر في أزمة، زي اللي صار في كورونا مثلًا
في بعض الشركات قلّصت الإنتاجية وتأثرت كثير
قالت: أنا راح أدفع ربع، ما أدري نص راتب، ما أقدر أتواكب، وإلا راح نقفل
فالموظفين يصيرون شايلين للشركة في الأزمات، في المواقف اللي صارت قبل
أنا مرت علي حالات كثيرة...
اسمح لي أقول لك واحد من الأمثلة
عندنا واحد من الموظفين جاء له مولود قبل وقته، يسمونهم الخُدّج
التأمين الطبي ما يغطي إلا شهر أو شهرين وبعدين راح يتكفل فيها الموظف
موقف صعب جدًّا على الموظف، وأعتقد إيجار الحاضنة
أربع أو خمس آلاف ريال في المستشفيات الخاصة
رحنا حق المدير الإقليمي في الموارد البشرية
لأن مدير الموارد البشرية في المنطقة ما يقدر يأخذ قرار مثل هذا
لأنه ما نعرف متى الطفل يقدر يستغني عن الحاضنة، ممكن تمر شهور
فرحنا للمدير الإقليمي، قال: والله قرار صعب
لأن التكلفة قد تتجاوز نص مليون، لأنه أربع شهور
ويمكن محتاج له أربع شهور ثانية
فقال: خلوني أتكلم مع نائب المدير أو المدير العام، عشان...
شوف أنت لما تعرف أن الكل مهتم، على طاري احنا كيف نهتم
أنت تبدأ حتى لو ما صارت موافقة
يا أخي يكفي أن الناس قاعدة تسعى لهذا الشخص
والله فعلًا وافق المدير العام
وقال: إذا أن الحالة إنسانية ما نقدر نتخلى عن موظفنا في مثل هذه الظروف
شاعت القصة في الشركة بعدما جاءت الموافقة
وأن الموظف كان متأثر كثير أنه ممكن يفقد طفله في هذيك الفترة
كمية الولاء زادت عندنا، وصارت الإيجابية موجودة كثير
الناس تتكلم أنه فعلًا شركة تهتم في موظفينها في الخارج
فاحنا، وهذا اللي لمسناه على فكرة في موظفين خلال الأزمات
والله يا عبدالرحمن، في ناس كانت تنام عندنا في الشركة
أقسم بالله، أحيانًا نمر في أزمة شحن، ونبغى نصدّر، وما احنا قادرين
في ناس، أحيانًا تيجي أمطار على المدينة تضطر أنك ما تقدر تطلع وترجع البيت
فما راح تقدر تؤدي شغلك في اليوم الثاني
يقول لك: أنا مضطر أني أنام في...
احنا ما نطلب
ونقول لواحد: لا، عشان أولادك أو هذا خطر عليك
يقول: لا يمكن، الشركة كانت توقف معي في الأزمات
هذا الولاء اللي يجيك من الموظفين من الاهتمام
ففي بعض الشركات تتبنى هذه المواقف، لأنها تعرف أن انعكاساتها
المستفيد بالدرجة الأولى هي المنظومة والشركة ما رميناها عبث
الكل ربحان
ما في شك، والمواقف كثيرة، ما أبغى أحكيلك
أنا في رحلة طويلة وقفت على هذه المواقف بنفسي
شفت أن فعلًا أن في موظفين لا يمكن ينسون هذه المواقف
وعلى فكرة يصدرونها للأولاد، والأولاد يصدرونها لعيال عمهم وعيال خالهم
فيصير معروف أن شركة بابا سوّت معنا كذا، وحصل معنا كذا
وهذه هي السمعة المهمة اللي تسعى لها الشركات كذلك
وهي برضو أحس أنها جزء معقد منها، لأن المفترض أن الشركات ما تتعامل
بهذه العلاقات التعاقدية، وأنها تكون تراحمية إنسانية
بغض النظر عن المنفعة، اللي تجي منها للطرفين
لكن هم الموارد البشرية اللي يخوفون دائمًا
لا، خلني أصحح لك معلومة عشان لا تقلبها علينا
تبنّي مثل هذه الأمور مش الموارد البشرية
هذه الشركة الأم والإدارة العامة
وعلى فكرة في شركات عائلية عندنا موجودة في البلد تتبنّى هذه الأمور
مرّت علي مواقف كثيرة، ما أبغى أتكلم بس على الشركات العالمية
لا، في شركات تتبنى هذا الموضوع من الإدارة
مش من الموارد البشرية، أنت لما تعزز هذا المفهوم
الموارد البشرية في النهاية يطبقون تعليمات
أقدر أجيب لك موافقة بناءً على التأمين مثلًا
ما أقدر أتخطى هذا الموضوع أو أنت معطيني تجاوز معين
بس أني أرفعها كذا كثير، لازم أروح حق راعي الحلال
أقول له: فلوسك بتطير
لأن في حلقة موجودة في مربّع، برضو لشركة سعودية
كان مديرها وصاحبها، تجربتهم رائعة
كيف العلاقة تتجاوز مجرد الموظف حتى إلى عائلة الموظف
احنا عندنا في الشركة عبدالرحمن موظفين يوم قربوا على التقاعد
توظفوا عيالهم، إي والله، وتشوف الشبه
هذا طالع خلاص آخر عمره، وهذا جايب ولده
من وين تجي هذه؟ من هذا الاهتمام
يقول لك: ولدي في مأمن في هذا المكان
وزي ما قلتك هذا مش منطبق على الشركات
احنا عندنا في السعودية في شركات كبيرة
وحتى شركات عائلية تتبنى هذه المبادئ
هل من المنطقي والصحي للموظف أن يستمر في شركة واحدة فترة طويلة؟
وللا إذا طول أكثر من أربع سنين المفترض أن يلقى له وظيفة ثانية
عشان تجربة جديدة؟
والله شوف هي لها معطيات كثيرة، إذا أنت عندك مقوّمات معينة
أهداف وخطط أنت راسمها لنفسك، بناءً عليها تقدر تأخذ القرار
بمعنى أن اليوم أنا أتطور وظيفيًّا ومهنيًّا
والمنظومة اللي أنا قاعد أشتغل فيها، تعاملني بالمثل
أكيد اليوم احنا بعد عشر سنوات، ما احنا قبل عشر سنوات
فمدام الشركة تكبر، وأنا أكبر معاها
وهذا شيء يعطيني حسب متطلبات السوق
فأنا ما يمنع أن أستمر في هذا المكان، وأكمل رحلتي المهنية
فالموارد البشرية ما تشوفها عيب استمرار موظف فترة طويلة
مثلًا عشرة أو خمسة عشر سنة في شركة واحدة؟
لا، طالما أن لما تقرأ السيرة الذاتية، وتشوف المناصب اللي تقلدها منطقية
مقارنةً بسنين العمر، أموره طبيعية
بس لما أشوف واحد ينتقل على سلم واحد بدون ما يكون فيها تحسين
أكيد أيش قاعد تسوي كل هذه المدة هنا؟ الخطأ هنا
هنا يبدأوا الموارد البشرية يدققون عليك
أيش قاعد تسوي خمسة عشر سنة في مكان واحد؟
معناها ما تطورت، وأنت ما زادت مهاراتك
ومعناها أنت اللي اشتغلت فيه في البداية
أنت موجود عليه فأنت ما تفيدني بعد عشر سنوات
فالاهتمام المهاري والتقني والتطور إذا ما كان مستمر
أنت قطعًا صعب تلقى وظيفة
وهذا كثير من الناس اليوم يسألوننا
يقول لك: يا أخي أنا أبغى أطلع من مكاني الوظيفي بعد خمس سنوات
هل سيرتك الذاتية ومهاراتك تغيرت؟
هل أنت نفس الشخص اللي قبل خمس سنوات؟
أكيد، أنت صرت قديم بالنسبة لنا
فالقرار يعود على الشخص، وأيش جهز للمرحلة القادمة؟ وتقدر تستمر
أعرف كثيرين خصوصًا لما يتصلون في شركات كبيرة
بدأوا مع الشركة، والآن هم في مناصب قيادية عالية
إلا إذا جاءت المغريات
أحيانًا تكون المناصب الكبيرة والرواتب الضخمة
اللي تخليه أنه ممكن يغيّر بعد كل رحلة العمر
بس أكيد عنده إنجازات ساعدته في أن يصل للي وصل له
لأن أحيانًا في بعض الشركات، يصل لمدير عام
بس خلاص ما عاد في شيء
ما في شيء أعلى منه
إي، ما في نائب مدير، أو مدير تنفيذي، أو شغلة زي كذا
فيبدأ خلاص يتوجه أن أنا سويت كل شيء في هذا المكان
جاء الوقت للانتقال إلى المرحلة اللي بعدها، بس التسلسل
مهم
نعم
ويعطي دلالة أنك ما عندك هم تطوير نفسك حتى
لما تقعد فترة طويلة في نفس المكان، ونفس المنصب
يعطي دلالة أنك إنسان غير مهتم وغير متطور
ولا تحب أصلًا أنك تتطور
وفي ناس كذا، وتقول لك: أنا يا أبوي ما أبي أتطور ولا تقرّب
إي والله، ولا تقرّب منّي ولا تعطيني مسؤولية
ما أبغى أخذ أي مسؤولية، هذا مكتبي
عشرين سنة هذا أنا قاعد وهذه شغلتي، إلى أن يقولوا لي: تقاعد
في والله أمثلة كثيرة
في إحصائيات تقول أن أقل من 50% من الناس يطلبون ترقية
فواضح أن الناس ما تطلب ترقيات
متى الموظف يطلب ترقية؟
شوف، الحوافز سواءً ترقية أو زيادة لأنها تعتبر حوافز
الحوافز لما تجي تطلب، لازم يكون في قبلها رحلة
لازم يكون في قبلها إنجاز
قبل كذا أنت المفروض ما تجي بداية السنة إلا أنت عندك أهداف
جلست مع الإدارة ومع مديرك والقسم
أن أهدافنا توزعت علينا، وأن راح نجي في نهاية السنة
راح نقول من اللي أنجز الأهداف؟
ومن اللي أنجز أزيد، اللي فاق التوقعات، وحقق منجزات يُعتَد فيها؟
مو منجزات، تقول لي: غيرت المكاتب من هنا إلى هنا
لا، وفّرت على الشركة ملايين
حققنا مشروع كان من المفترض أن يُنجز خلال ثلاثة شهور جبناه في شهر
سلسلة الإنجازات خلال السنة، وهي رحلة مستمرة
نهاية السنة أنا أدخل وأطلب، ورأسي مرفوع
لأن احنا حققنا أهدافنا، وأزيد من أهدافنا في توقيت قبل اللي كان مخطط له
هنا تطلب زيادة أو حوافز، ولكن لازم تعتَد بشغلة مهمة
أنك لازم تتماشى مع أنظمة الشركة اللي أنت فيها
في بعض الشركات، لأن هو مش إجباري
ما تقدر تجبر الشركة تقول: تعالوا أعطوني وزيدوني ورقّوني
لأن لازم تكون منطقي، ما نبغى نتكلم بحماس
وندفع الناس بكرة يروحون يطلبون ترقية أو زيادة
هل في شواغر موجودة؟
هل أنت شايف مكان بمستوى أعلى من مستواك، هذا واحد
هل أنت جدير أنك تمسك هذه المسؤولية؟
لأنك لو وصلت وما كنت قد المسؤولية، السقطة قوية راح تجي عليك
راح تتأثر كثير، لو قالوا: رجعوه، سوّى لنا مشكلة كبيرة
فهذه من الأمور اللي لازم تتحقق منها قبل أن تطلب
موضوع الزيادات، أنت حققت، وعندك منجزات وفعلًا
بس هل أنت اليوم الشركة في لوائحها تصرف زيادات
بشكل سنوي أو بشكل سنتين؟
في شركات، احنا عندنا في الشركة ممكن تصل
كل ستة شهور يُصرف لك زيادة، إي والله إذا كنت وإنجازاتك خارق
وأنقذت الشركة من مشاكل
أو حققت مشروع كان المفروض يأخذ سنة جبته في ستة شهور
ممكن تشوف العجب، في شركات...
هو على حسب لوائح الشركة الداخلية؟
إيوة، فلازم تكون منطقي في طلباتك
واحد يجيني يقول: أبغى ترقية، وأنت لا حققت أهدافك
ولا ساعدت المجموعة في تحقيق أهدافها
ولا قدمت لنا ولا خدمة صغيرة خلتنا نتطور عن السنة اللي راحت
ما لك حق تطلب هذه الزيادة، لأن ما في أي إضافة
والترقية نفس الشيء ، قبل أن تطلب
زي ما قلت لك: لازم تكون متأكد أنه في مكان للترقية
لأن أحيانًا احنا مثلًا عدد المدراء خمسة، وعدد اللي تحت المدراء عشرة
واحد من المدراء صار مدير عام، فصار في شاغر وظيفي واحد
ما أقدر أرقي من العشرة إلّا واحد
وراح أختار الأفضل، واللي حقق أهداف ومنجزات، ويتحمل مسؤولية
بس ما أقدر أرقيكم كلكم، لأن حسب الهيكل الوظيفي اللي قدامي في واحد
ممكن السنة الجاية يكونوا اثنين
ممكن السنة اللي بعدها ما يكون في ولا أحد لأن ما في مكان
فالترقيات محكومة بلوائح وأنظمة والشواغر
والزيادات محكومة بميزانيات القسم
هل في منجزات، وهل تستحق؟ راح تأخذ
أغلب الناس ما عندهم مهارات أو لا يرغبون أنهم يكونوا مدراء
وفهمت من كلامك مثلًا، ويبدو أن هذا الطبيعي
أن أنا عشان أتطور مهنيًّا أو يزيد راتبي، لازم أكون مدير؟
طيب، أنا ما أبغى أصير مدير
إذا ما تبغى تصير مدير
لأن يمكن ما عندي مهارات إدارية لكنّي والله ميكانيكي جيد
أو عندي قدرات في الهندسة ميكانيكية، أو معماري رائع
أنا أحب أرسم، أبغى أصمم، بس ما أبغى أدير ناس تحتي
لا، هو مو شرط أنك تكون مدير عشان أنك تحقق منجزات
بس عشان تكون مدير، لازم تكون مدير على إدارة
المدير محكوم بالإدارة
يوم من الأيام، الحين من وين جاءوا؟
ما جاء المدير من فراغ، جاء بتسلسل هرمي واضح في مسار عمله
أنا أعرف أني راح أبدأ ميكانيكي، ثم مشرف الميكانيكيين، ثم مدير قسم الميكانيكا
بس أنا ما أبغى أصير مدير
ما تبغى تصير مدير خلّك مكانك ولا تطلب لا زيادة ولا ترقية
ليش؟
لأنّك راح تصل لمرحلة، مسؤولياتك محدودة
شلون تجي الزيادة أو الرواتب؟
مثلًا احنا نبدأ رواتب الكهربائيين بـ5000 ريال
والمشرفين بـ 10 ألاف ريال، ومدراء الأقسام بـ 15 ألف
ومدراء الإدارات تبدأ رواتبهم بـ 25 ألف
أنت جاي تبغى تصير كهربائي بـ 25 ألف؟
يمكنني أفضل كهربائي عندكم في الشركة في السعودية كلها
ستصل إلى السقف، سقف الراتب لا يمكن أن يتجاوز هذا المستوى
إلا لما تتخطى إلى المستوى الآخر، يسمونه منحنى أو مستوى الرواتب
هل تعتقد أنها عُطب في النظام؟
لا، أنا أعتبره، عشان أنت راح تأخذ على قدر المسؤولية
الآن ليش المدراء التنفيذيين رواتبهم عالية؟
لأن قرار واحد، ممكن يفلس الشركة، فمسؤولياته كبيرة
وهذا يشتغل في اليوم يمكن أكثر من أربع وعشرين ساعة
اليوم أربع وعشرينساعة، وهو يشتغل أكثر، لأن خطرة وظيفته
فهذا لا يقبل أن يتوظف في وظيفة إلا براتب مجزي، مسؤولياته كبيرة
هل هذا أقارنه باللي كل يوم يجي يربط لي مسمار
ويقول لي: تعال أعطيني زيادة، وإلا ميكانيكي زي ما أنت تقول؟
أنت حكمت على نفسك أنك تكون ميكانيكي
بس أنا بتخيل معك لنفرض
ميكانيكي أيش راح تسوي أكثر من أنك تكون...
لأن الميكانيكي يمكن يربطك في زاوية محددة
بس خلني أخذ مثال، إذا افترضنا مصمم معماري زي «زها حديد»
أنا أقدر أصمم لك أفضل مبنى أنت تقدر تبيعه
أنت تروح بيعه، ودير الناس، خلني أصممه، أنا ما أبغى أسوي شيء ثاني
ليش تخليني أدير الناس؟ أنا ما عندي مهارات إدارية
طيب أنت...
فهل معقول أني ما أقدر أخذ فلوس، لأني ما أبغى أصير مدير؟
إي، لأنك ما بغيت أنك تتحمل المسؤولية أكثر
لأن أنت إذا مصمم ومعماري كويس، لازم تكون رئيس المعماريين
بس تدري أن يمكن مو كل الناس قادرين على الإدارة
صحيح
مهما علّمته، في ناس انطوائيين أو أنه ما يحب
بس شوف أبو عمر، الإدارة هي مهارة
تتطلب منك أنك تكتسب مهارات، وهذه تجي مع الخبرة
احنا ما وصلنا مدراء كذا، نمنا وصحينا، وللا بعد خبرة معينة
في مهارات اكتسبناها، وفي مهارات تدربنا عليها
ما في واحد يجي يقول لك: أنا أنفع مدير وأقود مجموعة
يسمونها قيادة الأفراد، ما في أحد كذا، ولكن كنا مشرفين في البداية
مدير قسم العلاقات، معي فريق، أدير اثنين أو ثلاثة
بعدين، صرت مدير الخدمات في الموارد البشرية، زاد العدد
بعدين صرت مدير موارد البشرية، زاد العدد
اللي يحكم على نفسه أنه ما يبغى يكون مدير إدارة
لأن مسؤولياتك قليلة، ما نقدر نعطيك راتب كبير
حتى لو أنت كنت عبقري زمانك في قسمك، مستحيل
على قدر المسؤولية، ستأخذ الراتب
الآن أنا وزير، وهذا جاء في الوزارة
أنا صار لي سنة وزير، وقراراتي مأخوذة، وتعد بعين الاعتبار وخطرة
تشكّل موضوع كبير
وهذا صار له في الوزارة عشرين سنة في نفس المكان
كل ما جينا نرقيه، قال: ما أبغى
تعال تحمّل المسؤولية أو دير أفراد، ما أبغى
لا يمكن، مسؤولياتك قليلة راح تأخذ عليها
وهذا شيء، ما أدري إذا أنت تشوفه سلبي أو إيجابي
بس هذا شيء إيجابي يعزز التطور في الرحلة المهنية
أيش اللي يحفزك أنك تتطور؟
أن أنا أبغى أصل إلى مناصب عليا في الهيكل والسلم الوظيفي
كيف أصل؟
لازم أكتسب مهارات وقدرات ومسؤوليات
في النهاية، تبي تصير مكاني، أنا اليوم مدير
أنت تبي تصير مكاني؟ خلك قد المسؤولية
لازم يكون عندك مهارة الاحترافية في العمل
ولازم تعرف تحل المشاكل، وتدير الأزمات، وتدير الأفراد
عندك المهارات هذه؟ لا، إذن طوّرها
بكرة في يوم من الأيام أنا راح أمشي في مكان ممكن أعلى
أو ممكن نفسه، مو أنت راح تجي مكاني
عشان كذا لو تلاحظ في الرحلة المهنية
ممكن في أحد من موظفينك اللي جبته وترقّى يصير زميلك
نكون كلنا في نفس المستوى
لأن في ناس اهتمت أنها تطور من المهارات القيادية
عشان يقدر يمشي في الرحلة المهنية، وهذا حافز طيب
تخيل أن أنت تجيك زيادة كل سنة 3000 ريال
أو 2000 ريال، وأنت في نفس المكان
أيش الإبداع اللي راح تقدمه، وهي الزيادة مضمونة؟
وأنا جالس أؤدي كل يوم نفس الشغل
ما في أي إبداع وابتكارات، لأن لما يكون الشيء مضمون
صدقني المنظومة عمرها صغير، وراح تفلّس
يمكن أنا هنا بختلف معك شوي
لأن أتوقع أنه يختلف في المجالات الإبداعية
يمكن لأنك أنت تحتاج أن يطور مهاراته في...
هو كل يوم يبتكر لك فكرة فلم جديد
فهذه مهارته اللي تقوم الشركة عليها، ممكن
فليس بالضرورة المدراء، ممكن يكون هو راتبه أعلى من مديره
ممكن، خليني أقول لك شيء
المحترفين في العمل، عشان الإبداع تدري أيش يسوون؟
على سبيل المثال قوقل عندهم ناس حتى غرف نوم عندهم في مكان العمل
عشان يريحونهم دماغيًّا، ويبدأ صافي الدهن
يعطونهم نسبة من ربح الفكرة اللي هو جابها
صحيح، أنت ما راح تكون مدير، أنت مُبرمج
وعمرك كله راح تقضيه مُبرمج، بس كلما جبت فكرة إبداعية وبعناها
لك نصيب فيها
فهذه هي الطريقة اللي أنت تتكلم عنها
يمكن بس تختلف من شركة لشركة، فما في شك
يبقى آخر حاجة، اللي هي علاقة الموظف بمديره
كيف يحكمها؟
تبقى علاقة جافة رسميّة أو يطيّح الميانة؟
أيش الشكل المثالي لها؟
لا، شوف هي ما توصل أنك تطيّح الميانة
ولكن، يعلم الله، أنا مروا علي مدراء
وصلوا إلى مرحلة من العلاقات إلى أكثر من إخوان
لأن احنا سمحنا لبعض أن احنا نبني علاقة كويسة
وقفنا معهم في أزماتهم، ووقفوا معنا في أزماتنا
واحد من المدراء اسمه أستاذ «ماهر المقبقب»
بالتحديد عشان أقول اسمه
أنا مرة تنوّم الوالد في المستشفى، وما كان عندي رصيد إجازات
وكنت أنا الموجود مع الوالد هذيك الفترة
فقلت له: أنا مضطر أني أروح الدوام وأرجع كل يوم
لأن ما عندي رصيد إجازات
قال لي: أنت خلك مع الوالد، وخذ اللابتوب معك
الوالد تنوّم شهر ممكن
ولا تجي الدوام إلا لما يطلع من المستشفى
قلت له: يا ابن الحلال تبي تفصلنا؟ أنا...
قال لي: سوي اللي أقول لك عليه، وخلّي اللابتوب معك
لو احتجتك، راح أكلّمك
هذا الموقف أنا أقول لك: صار معي، والمواقف كثيرة مع مدراء كثر
هذا الموقف أنا عمري ما أنساه؛ لأن موقف أخَوِي
غير عن موقف مدير لموظفّه
وهو الشخص لما يفتح لك مجال أن تكون هذه العلاقة أخوية
وتروح لبعيد، فهذه من الأمور اللي أنت عمرك ما راح تنساها
ولا راح تنسى هذا الرجل
مع أنه هو الآن في شركة وأنا في شركة
بس لحد الآن تربطنا علاقة ونتواصل، لأن الموقف أثّر فيني وفي أهلي
و أثّر في الأولاد، لأنه كنت قد أُفصَل من العمل بسبب هذا الموقف
فمن اللي يحدد علاقتك مع مديرك؟
هو مدى المسافات اللي حطيتوها ما بينكم
تمر علينا مدراء، مجرد ما يدخل ويخلّص الفترة حقته ويروح
يكون في بحر النسيان مثلما يقولون
في جزئية أحب أعلّق عليها في هذا الموضوع، أن الموظف الذكي وظيفيًّا تحديدًا
هو اللي يعرف مفاتيح المدير
هو اللي يعرف طريقة وأسلوب المدير اللي يحب يشتغل فيه مع المجموعة
لا يمكن أنا اليوم يجيني أبو عمر
يقول لي: أنا هذه استراتيجيتي في العمل
أحب الانضباط، وما أحب أحد يتأخر
أحب أن احنا نؤدي شغلنا كل يوم من الساعة 8:00 إلى الساعة 16:00
لا أحد يقول لي: بطلع...، أحب الانضباط في العمل
هذا تلقاه في الشركات الأمريكية خصوصًا
عندهم الدوام لو جئت 20:05 يدق عليك، مش يقول لك: وينك؟
يخاف عليك، يقول لك: لا يكون صار عليك حادث؟
لأني أعرف أنك بتكون الساعة 20:00
أكيد المانع، خمس دقائق، والله ما أكذب عليك
يجي «أيمن» مثلًا يقول: يا جماعة أنا يهمني النتائج
بغض النظر عن كل شيء في العمل، حققوا لي منجزات
أهدافكم تجيبونها، تقعد في مكتبك أو في مطعم برة، أو في مقهى
اليوم ما تبغى تجي ما يهمني، أسلوبي في العمل المنجزات
أنتج في المكان اللي أنت تقدر تنتج فيه
فأنت لما تعرف لغة مديرك، تعرف اهتماماته وتوجهاته
وأسلوبه في العمل، ثِق تمامًا راح تنجح، وهذا يوديني إلى نقطة أخرى
معليش طولت عليك
لا بالعكس
يوديني إلى أن في كثيرين من الناس تجي
أول ما تجي في وظيفة، يقول: هذا المدير الله يعيننا عليه
لأنه صراحة صعب التعامل معه، ومن أسوأ الفترات
يمكن أنت واحد منهم
أشوف «أيمن» يضحك
من أصعب الفترات اللي تجينا أن هذا المدير عندنا
يجي «أيمن» يكتشف، لا والله أبو عمر واحد ثاني
يا أخي والله أسلوبه كويس ومحترم
ويعطينا الشغل، وأنا قاعد أعطيه شغل
فأنت تكتشف أن المشكلة مو في المدير
مع الأسف، والله أقول هذه الرسالة
تكتشف أن المشكلة في المجموعة اللي كانت حوالينا أو فيك أنت بعد
أنت أحيانًا ما قدرت تصل للمدير وما فهمته بشكل جيد
فالمدير أيش همه في الأخير؟
لو كان عادل ونزيه ومنصف وعنده مبدأ تكافؤ الفرص ما بين الموظفين
ما يفضل أحد على أحد
ثِق تمامًا أنه في النهاية يهمّه المنتج اللي راح يطلع من وراك
فقط لا غير
اعرف شلون تدخل له، وكيف تكسبه من خلال اهتماماته
والمدير عنده أهداف، من اللي يحقق أهداف المدير؟
الموظف، أنت
أنت تديرني عشان أحقق أهدافك
وأهدافك جاية من فوق من الإدارة العليا
فالمدير الجيد اللي يعرف يستخدم موظفينه، ويخليهم يحققوا الأهداف
واللي يعرف في يوم من الأيام أنه هو راح يترك مكانه
وراح يجي واحد من هذه المجموعة يمسك مكانه
فهذه هي سمة العلاقة الناجحة ما بين الموظف والمدير
كيف أختلف مع مديري بدون ما يفصلني؟
لا، ما تصل للفصل، بس يمكن يحقد عليك
طيب إذا حقد علي؟
احنا بطبيعتنا كبشر ما نحب النقد في العوام
وللا أنك تُخَطّئ أحد أمام المجموعة
نجي هنا للمدير، في أعراف وتقاليد
تصير مع المدراء، يا أخي أنا مدير
أول شيء لازم تتكلم معي باحترام
لا تطيّح ميانة مع مدير احذر أنك تمون على المدير، وهو ما سمح لك
وأنا مروا علي مدراء
أمون عليه حتى في التليفون، وأسولفه يا ابن الحلال أنت كذاب
أقول له: أنت كذاب قدام الشباب، كأني طعنته
وصارت لي مواقف أحرجني
قال لي: أنا أعرفك من زمان، بس ما تكلمني قدام الموظفين بالشكل هذا
فلازم تعرف كيف تتعامل، وتحترم المدير في المجموعة
طيب المدير، أنت تقول تبي تنتقده أو عندك معه مشكلة تبي تقوله إيّاها
لازم تختار أول شي الوقت والزمان المناسبين
لا تخطّئه أمام المجموعة، ولا تجي له في وقت وأزمة
تقول له: تعال ساعدني أنا أبغاك عندي مشكلة، مو فاضيلك
اختار المكان والزمان والأسلوب المناسب مع المدير، ويتقبلون
خصوصًا لازم تحط في بالك نقطة مهمة
هل أبو عمر يتقبل الاختلاف؟
في مدراء ما يتقبل، لا تتكلم معي، أنا اللي أقوله الصح
أنت دامك تعرف أن مديرك ما يتقبل النقد والاختلاف
لا تجيه في الشيء اللي ما يبغاه
ولكن أنت تعرف عنه أن هو يحب التغذية الراجعة
ويحب إذا أخطأ، يجي له الموظف، ويقول له
دائمًا يقول لك: في مثل هذه العلاقة حسب ما تعلّمنا ودرسنا
أنك لا تركّز على الأمور الشخصية في المدير
ركّز على المشكلة اللي أنت جاي تتكلم فيها
أنا أحترمك كموظف، لا تجيني تقول لي: أنت فيك
قُل لي: أيش المشكلة عشان أساعدك
في مقولة لـ «ستيفن كوفي» مرة حلوة أحبها
يقول لك: الموظف إذا جاب لك المشكلة فهو مراسل
وإذا جاب لك المشكلة مع حل هو مستشار
وإذا جاءك وهو حال المشكلة فهو قائد
فأنت اختار أي واحد تروح تتكلم مع المدير
طبعًا اللي يحبونه المدراء، اللي جايب لهم المشكلة محلولة
ما قدرت، تعال وعندك الحل
بس جاي تقول لي: فلان فيه، واحنا سوينا مشكلة هناك
أنت معناها أنك مراسل، بس ما شغلتك إلا تنقل الكلام
فهذه مقولة حلوة لـ«ستيفن كوفي»
اختيار الأسلوب والطريقة مع المدير باحترام جدًّا مهمة والزمان والمكان
وهل هو يسمح بهذا الشيء وللا لا؟
لازم تكون عارفها قبل لا تروح تسوي لك مشكلة، ويطردك على قولتك
متى يُطرد؟ ما أحد يُطرد، مو بكيفك
مو بكيف المدير اليوم يصحى تكلّمت معي بأسلوب، يقول لك: اطلع
لا مو بالطريقة هذه، بس ممكن يحطك في زاوية الغير مهتم فيهم
وهذه على فكرة مروا علي حالات بنات وأولاد
أن المدير حطه على الدكّة مثلما يقولون
أهون علي أني أطلع من الشركة ولا أجلس هذه الجلسة
وهذه تحدث في الكرة لما يصير اللاعب ما يتفاهم مع المدرب
ويطلع ويصرخ وهذا
المباراتان اللي بعدها في المدرج، يحرقه حرق
ويأخذ درس قاسي، كيف يرجع مرة ثانية إلى الأساسيين؟
فهذه ما هي بسهلة على الواحد
خّلك من الطرد، هذه أسوأ من الطرد
إذا صارت مشكلة، متى يحلّها ودّيًّا، ومتى يتوجه إلى الموارد البشرية؟
الموظف؟
إي، بينه وبين مديره
بينه وبين مديره؟
أيش الشكل المثالي لحل المشاكل؟
هي ما تجي كذا، هي تجي أن بطبيعة العمل بيئة فيها مشاكل كثيرة
فيها مشادّات، وأخذ وعطاء وزعل
هذه هي البيئة، ما في بيئة عمل ما فيها هوشات
ما أدري أنتوا في ثمانية كيف، بس احنا ما يمر علينا إلا يصير في سوء تفاهم
ووجهات نظر مختلفة، هذه طبيعتها
أحسن وأسرع وأجمل طريق هي المواجهة
في مشكلة كبيرة أن أنا يمرون علي ناس
يقول لي: يا أخي مديري... تكلّمت معه؟ لا والله
يا أخي قاعد يعاملنا بالطريقة هذه...
سألته؟ لا والله
تدري وين تصير المشكلة؟
تصير المشكلة في الشخص نفسه، والله العظيم
وهذه بنسبة تفوق 80%
ليش؟ لأنه يتصرف تصرفات تنعكس على المدير
هذاك يوم من الأيام
واحنا قاعدين في اجتماع، والمدير يتكلم، يقاطع كثير
عصب المدير، يقول: يا أخي لا تجيبونه اجتماع مرة ثانية
عندنا ضيوف وزوّار، أنت ما عندك فرصة أنك تتكلم
ما كان عندك جزء، بس احنا حاضرين
أبديت رأي غلط ما هو مطلوب منك
ما يعرف الموظف، بس المدير مُحرج ما يبغى يقول لك
عشان لا تأخذ... بس بدأ يأخذ عليك موقف
لما تواجهه، قل له: يا أخي أنا حاسك أن أخذت موقف مني
صارت لي مشكلة وأحس أنك أنت تبي توضح لي شيء أنا مو فاهمه
حسيتك بدأت تعمل معي مشاكل أنا ما أعرفها
يا أخي أنت إنسان لما تحضر معنا في اجتماع ما تسكت
أنت دائمًا تأتي متأخر الاجتماعات
أنت دائمًا أشوفك تأخذ استراحة وتطلع برة، وترجع بعد ساعتين
أنا ساكت عنك، بس ماني براضٍ
فلما تواجه، وقد يكون المدير في مشاكل بعد كثيرة
يقول لك: يا أخي أنت تعاملنا بعنف شوي، أنا استأذنت منك بروح أودي مرض
أودي عيالي عندهم موعد، رفضت
أنا أحيانًا حسيت أن في فرصة تدريبية أبغى أخذها
أنت ما أعطيني إياها
يقول المدير: والله ما كنت منتبه أو ما كنت عارف
أو فكرت الموضوع عادي، بس حزّت في خاطرك
فالمواجهة أفضل وأسرع طريقة لحل المشاكل
بس احنا ما نتجرأ نتكلم مع المدراء
مع أن أحيانًا المدير يتغير 180 درجة لما تواجهه، ويعرف مشاكله
متى أروح الموارد البشرية؟
الموارد البشرية موجودة لتطبق اللوائح والأنظمة
لما يتجاوز المدير حدود المهنة بالألفاظ والتصرفات
يعني تكون ألفاظ غير سوية، ويتجاوز.....
احنا نسميها الشللية في العمل
يعني عنده أشخاص يفضلهم على أشخاص
هؤلاء من منطقته، وهؤلاء مش من منطقته
هؤلاء من جماعته، وهؤلاء مش من جماعته
معناها أنه بدأ يدخل في مسألة التحزبات
واضح أنه يميل لمجموعة على مجموعة
وأن الترقيات والزيادة.... في مخالفات واضحة وصريحة
هنا لازم يتحول الموضوع إلى الموارد البشرية
لأن لو تركته سيتمادى كثير، وراح تخسر كثير
فهنا ما ينفع تقعد معه، لو جلست معه، راح يزيد الطين بلّة
راح يحجّمك أكثر بعد من اللازم
فلازم تروح تتوجه للموارد البشرية لأن في تجاوزات
حسب الأنظمة واللوائح في الشركة
أن تجاوزات والحبّية والشللية والألفاظ
ولو لا قدر الله، صار حتى في أدبيًّا ما قاعد يتعامل معانا بأدب
فلازم تتدخل الموارد البشرية، وتجلس مع المدير المباشر
عشان توضح له جزئيات قد تتسبب في أنه يتم الاستغناء عنه من العمل
لأنه ما بعد الأخلاق شيء، وما وصلنا لهذه المرحلة، ليش؟
أركز بس على هذه الجزئية
لو المنظومات والشركات كانت تثقّف موظفينها باستمرار في هذا الجانب
بمعنى أن اليوم إذا أي تجاوز أخلاقي في المهنة
هذا يؤدي إلى الفصل عمره ما أحد راح يتجاوز، بشكل مستمر
أنت كل ستة شهور نبّه وحذّر، وتجمع الناس أو ترسل بريد إلكتروني
يا جماعة نعيد رسالة التجاوزات الأخلاقية على الموظفين يؤدي إلى الاستغناء
خلاص تصير موجودة
عدم التجاوز على زملاء العمل، خلاص أنا أعرف
فهذه من الأمور اللي تحميك وتحميه، وما تخلي المنظومة تدخل في...
وتحمي المنظومة
إي، ففي شغل على الشركة وشغل على المدراء، وتثقف الموظفين
أحيانًا الموظفين يعانون من مشاكل كبيرة، بس ما يعرف يتكلم مع مين
فليش أقول لك السؤال كويس؟
أنت اليوم كموظف، حسيت بالظلم وفي تجاوزات
والله ما أكذب عليك، أنا مرّوا علي بعض الموظفين
حتى أحيانًا باليد يصير في لمس
والله يقول لي: أحيانًا يدف، وهو يتكلم معنا
وللا مثلًا يتلفّظ بألفاظ، ما هي ألفاظ
مثلًا يقول: أنتم أغبياء وما تفهمون، هذا تجاوز على الموظف
احنا جايين في مكان نحترم بعضنا، وللا جايين نتهزأ في المكان؟
فلازم تتوجه للموارد البشرية عشان يوجهون له رسالة
يقول لك: العيار اللي ما يصيب يدوش
بعد هذه إنذار، وممكن احنا نستغني عنك
الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك
شكرًا جزيلًا
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي في إعداد الحلقة
وخلف الكاميرات: وهاب موسى
وفي التحرير: محمد نور شمت
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
وفي التسجيل الصوتي: عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي تحرير الألوان: عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج: أيمن الحمادي
وفي إدارة التحرير: أسيل با عبدالله
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب، من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، ألقاكم